hey guys pete here there's only one
episode of better call saul left so i
thought we should jump on today and talk
about it again
one more time i mean it's this one of
those situations where i'm not really
worried about how it's going to end
uh i'm obviously been thinking about it
not really thinking about much else over
the last uh week or so but
i you know it's
there's this thing out there where they
said that this is going to be an ending
like something we hadn't seen before and
it
i i don't know i'll ask my guests this
the same question i'm really not sure if
that's if that's setting an unrealistic
expectation
and um you know i i do expect that this
is going to be you know satisfying
entertaining i don't i can't really see
a way where it wouldn't be those you
know those things and um
beyond that you know i i just
there's some things i want to see
there are some things that i hope happen
but
it could go so many different ways the
way they set it up it's just really open
to
you know
be surprising and i really like that so
i'm joined today by chase from the
channel the vivid kiwi i'll let you
introduce yourself um tell us what
you're thinking about going into the
finale
and then we'll we'll see if we get some
questions and we'll talk about the
teaser a little bit
and some other things and um
just try to enjoy this we only got one
one more episode to go so
might as well make the most of it
yeah exactly thanks pete so hey guys
kiwi here and um it's just it's crazy
it's crazy how we're so close to the end
of the show this is like one of the
final few moments that we have of not
knowing what's going to happen in better
call saul so trying to make it last as
much as we can i guess uh
i believe we both did prediction videos
earlier this week and it was a bit
cathartic doing my final prediction
video for better call saul ever um just
because we've been we've been doing this
for so long you know like this show's
been going on for what like six seven
years now uh with all the delays and
and uh you know the pandemic and all
that
um
apparently the next episode is going to
be extended i saw it's gonna be like an
hour and a half with commercials i think
it's gonna be probably like 70 or
something minutes without commercials so
they definitely got the time that they
need to uh to conclude this um i guess
we're mainly just focusing on gene and
kim right now and
i'm not too sure like as you said
there's a lot of open-ended
possibilities as to what can happen
um
but the thing is is that
i i guess i guess i want to open up by
asking this so
at the end of 611 uh gene is running or
612 sorry gene's running out of marion's
house and he's probably gonna go back
home to get his shoeboxers diamonds and
then flee again maybe try to relocate
but do you think that he's going to be
able to grab his shoebox and get out of
there before the police arrive at his
house or is he going to have to try and
run away without uh without his diamonds
there
yeah i you know i i do think he will i
because i think that the teaser when we
hear him uh repeating
the uh you know the ed the ed part and
of the i feel like he's doing the same
thing he did in 501 whenever jeff um
made him and visited him at the mall the
first time
so i do think that he'll go there it i
think there would be some response time
he he drove to marion's house
i don't think that she knows where he
lives um they never really made that
that clear but it it didn't seem like it
um
jeff never dropped him off there you
know we know he got freaked out the
first time he was in his car and and had
him drop him off
not even at the mall you know what i
mean so
um
i i think that
he's gonna get that far
and
you know the the only the only promo
photo is this one that with him wearing
the hat
um
yeah this one here so he's
it looks like he's to be moving around a
little bit
i when i look at this i thought this
might be him getting ready to like he's
looking at his own apartment or
something you know getting i'm getting
ready to go inside and i do think in the
teaser he's looking in the box like the
sound it sounds like it's you know
there's rustling going on and maybe you
can even hear the band-aid tin open
so
yeah i think he'll make it that far
but i think he'll be faced with a
decision there because you know what
where where where can he actually go you
know what i mean if he calls ed
that would be a super
unsatisfying ending you know what i mean
like if he just if he's just
snuck away and
you know it just doesn't seem like if
you got 70 minutes of tv left
that he's gonna be able to follow
through with that
so i guess what i'm i'm more interested
in is like what what happens to make him
because he has a he has a you know he he
has a backup plan we saw him put that
into play at the end of 501 or in 501 as
well you know i mean he he has a box he
has the diamonds he has a panamanian
passport as far as we could tell from
looking in the box before
so
i guess the my bigger question is why
doesn't he run
oh yeah yeah i'm not too sure because
i mean honestly if he does run uh i
assume that marion's gonna tell the
authorities that he's changed his
identity once so he'll probably do it
again
um and there probably already was like a
nation nationwide manhunt out for uh out
for saul the same way that it was for
for jesse and
so if he did hypothetically flee he'd
have to probably flee the country like
go into canada go down into mexico maybe
somehow get to i don't i don't know if
he'd go to alaska you know still
technically the states but um
it's just the thing about uh
robert forster sadly being pat having
passed away um i'm not sure if they're
going to have to try and right around it
but
even if uh robert forrester was still
with us i think that he wouldn't ed the
disappear wouldn't want to
uh help gene because he is just too hot
now and
i mean maybe that's why he wants to go
and get the diamonds because he was
already told that it would cost double
to relocate again but i am thinking that
he would have to try and relocate by
himself and i don't know how successful
he's going to uh
going to be with that
with the promo image it kind of does
like look like he's looking back on his
house now i'm not sure if that's because
he got there you know before the cops
got in got out got what he needed or
maybe he's going to his house and he
sees that the cops already there now it
is true that marion and jeff don't
really know where he lives and i assume
that the police are going to go to
marriott's house first and then talk to
her um yeah but it gives him a little
bit of time
yeah i assume that gene you know does
have that house under his gene tack of
it alias so it won't take them long to
uh look that up and figure out where he
does live so it's just a matter of if he
gets in or out and
something that i was thinking about
earlier today is the fact that
gene has the watches and everything that
he uh stole from the mark in 612 so you
know i'm assuming he'll go in and grab a
shoebox and leave he'll probably leave
the watches there i'm wondering if the
police will raid his house and find the
watches and they'll put two and two
together and eventually realize that hey
these are the watches that uh that were
stolen from that house that was broken
into the night before and maybe that'll
actually get jeff out of his charges uh
for being the main suspect of uh of
robbing that house because i mean he
didn't have any evidence on him and i
assume that the mark is gonna put out
like hey this is what was stolen and
they might uh they might find those
watches there and then realize that it
was saul goodman that broke into his
house
and it might get jeff off uh off
scot-free here well in regards to
breaking editing not so much uh hitting
a parked car but i was just wondering if
that's gonna go down because uh
just because the fact that it is kind of
crazy how saul has ruined the lives of
everyone around him right like now jeff
is in jail he's not going to be able to
get him out marion is terrified for her
life of you know from him uh and it's
really horrible what gene has done to
them uh on purpose or not but i'm
wondering if there's a little bit of
light at the end of the tunnel in
regards to jeff getting out of that b
and e charge just because they might
find those watches at saul's house
yeah i i think ultimately if um if
jeff's able to keep his mouth shut that
he'll get off either way because he he
really didn't do anything you know i
mean like he's
there's no evidence to tie him to that
um
but that doesn't mean that he won't be
freaked out and
you know crack under pressure or any of
any other thing you know number of
things that could happen to him while
he's in there i i've been thinking about
that like you know i don't know if we're
going to see a lot of marion and um jeff
other than to you know get the idea of
how it wraps up so that could be a way
through that you know what i mean like i
imagine that we will see marion talk to
the police
um
that she'll at least make an appearance
uh but if he goes if he goes on the run
then you know i don't know how big of a
part they'll play beyond that you know
we'll have to see like i said so many of
these things are just like
you could just go and and list off all
the different possibilities but but it's
really hard to say until we see how they
set things up and and as we're answering
these questions i'm sure we're going to
hit on all the different things so
yeah we start jumping into these right
now so naba down
nava down south thank you for the five
dollars lyle
comes in and takes out saul and kim for
the affidavit since he's in charge of
the lab now
uh i i feel like that there's a
possibility i feel like it's a pretty
low possibility for for
a lot of you know people to return um
there's there's some chance i guess if
he does go to trial or something like
that
but even in that
i don't think there's any chance that we
see lyle in the finale of this what do
you think
yeah i mean the thing about season six a
better call saul is they gave a lot of
the side characters like a final swan
song you know we saw rich we saw a lot
of cliff we saw the kettleman's etc the
camera crew and i feel like that scene
of uh lyle and uh what was it uh 607 i
think it was yeah i think that that was
his final scene and and i'm pretty sure
that in the you know post-breaking bad
timeline i don't i don't think that los
poyos is even a los poyos anymore right
i think it's uh yeah and what we saw at
the beginning of el camino with all the
breaking bad locations and such as uh
saul's office no longer being there so
i'm not even sure if the whole los poyos
franchise is shut down or or what the
deal is there but uh
you know hopefully lyle's living his
best life somewhere managing some other
store
yeah
yeah i i do think that that was his his
uh his
final shot you know the one that they
had they actually lingered on him and
gave him a little bit more than than
what was necessary to tell what was
happening there so it felt like it was
sort of like a you know a grace note or
something like that just to
send him off
roger rubio thank you for the 20 that is
very uh generous big shout out to my two
favorite bcs youtube creators kiwi and
pete thank you for all the entertainment
through the years
no your hard work is much appreciated
what has been your one favorite episode
in season six
well thank you for the kind words and
i was thinking about this yesterday
um it's it as as as the season was going
on it was sort of like
you know that it changed uh you know
obviously episode three was my my
favorite episode in the beginning of the
season
and then um episode seven
episode nine
and uh
episode 12. those were the ones that
after i was done watching i was like
okay that was the best thing i've seen
all season
and
you know after
after thinking about it lit i i don't
know i mean i think seven
might be
the best
overall episode as far as you know it
was set up perfectly
it did so many things i mean it's just a
completely tight hour
of television
um
but then you know like i thought nine
was was like kind of the most shocking
or the most
you know it was the stuff i was waiting
for and it surprised me
the most how how they were able to you
know play off all the all of the history
all of what they were
you know what the characters were about
and how um
how they they were able to deliver a
answer to the question that i had in a
in a way that didn't sound like
something that i wanted to see but when
i saw it it was it was you know just
completely satisfying and and it
made sense
you know way more than anything else
that that
people are throwing around might happen
so i don't know i think in the at the
end of the day it's probably going to be
down between those two i mean um
12 was fantastic
but it you know the ending is open and
you know that
it's set up what's going to happen next
and i think it's going to
you know i think that
it needed to do that
um but
i would say that you know if you look at
side by side i would say i like you know
episode seven
a little bit better
from you know technically speaking what
about you chase what do you think
oh geez well it's so hard because better
call saul just keeps topping itself over
and over again like we thought that
bagman and bad choice road were the best
episodes or even chicanery but now it's
season six there's just there's just so
many amazing episodes and i love how
this show's going out with a bang uh
it's really hard for a lot of shows to
stick the landing and i think that's one
thing that better call saul is not
struggling with and i think that episode
607 is amazing and then 608 being the
aftermath is really good 609 is awesome
uh conclude you know sort of an epilogue
for the 2004 era um i think i like 610
more than a lot of people i thought that
was really good but then 6 11 and 6 12
just wow um i think i'd put 609 and 612
sort of side by side and then i guess
it's really between 607 and 603
um as much as i love 607 because it is
just a genuinely strong episode ends
with a huge shocker and even though 603
was kind of more predictable like we
knew that nacho was going to die we just
didn't know when or how or what exactly
was gonna go down i think i'm gonna have
to go with 603 for my favorite episode
just because nacho's been my favorite
character the whole show you know even
though he doesn't get as much screen
time as a lot of other characters he's
always been my favorite i've always been
a michael mando fanboy since far cry 3.
um so i think i'm gonna have to go with
603 just because that episode just
impacted me so hard um even more so than
the howard death i i think i have to say
i mean i was straight up depressed after
episode 603 if you go and watch my video
of like the reaction to nachos fade you
can just sound that i sound straight up
sad in that video um so i think i'm
gonna have to go with 603 although 607 i
mean you can go with either or it's just
up to preference they're both top-tier
episodes
yeah yeah that's what that's what you
know it's i think it'll be one of those
things when you look back that they're
all they're all
pretty evenly you know evenly uh they
stack up pretty evenly and so whatever
wherever you find yourself
at the time you know you could go i was
really surprised i mean i i kind of uh
you know i when i looked at some i was
looking at something yesterday and i
guess i was just checking to see if
somehow they had put together a summary
and so i saw some of the ratings on imdb
and um
i was surprised that that
608 is rated so much higher than than
609 it really doesn't make sense to me
um
i thought 608 was fine but uh
it it doesn't it's not up there with the
other ones for me anyways um and and
generally speaking you know those
those ratings are or whatever you know
what i mean like everything's subjective
anyways
but you know the part that i thought was
weird about it was is that
on all the other episodes i was i was
kind of in the you know i was kind of in
agreement with what i'm seeing but that
one that one seemed like a big um
that one seemed like the anomaly of the
bunch and the rest are all you know
pretty much a's you know this is like a
range from a minus to eight pluses you
know what i mean
so let's see here michael key thank you
for the five dollars do you think a
satisfying ending would be jimmy does 10
years then lives happily ever after with
kim
um
not i mean this is this is complicated
um and it's a good question because it
touches on a couple of things that we're
gonna need to address uh
maybe more than once as we go through
this
um
jimmy you refer to the guy as jimmy
which you know that's
that's jimmy mcgill he's the star of a
better call saul
but he goes through a couple of
transformations in that time and um you
know this is where i was at the other
day when i made my preview video is i
would like to see him become
jimmy again i mean i i'd like to see
him in a situation where he doesn't
revert back to
these different you know better you know
he doesn't revert back to saul this
persona that he uses to shield himself
from all the pain that he's gone through
gene you know in hiding or whatever the
next in you know the next version the
gene would have been
and so
if you if you if you look at it from
that perspective if jimmy doing 10 years
and then getting
out then i guess you could kind of see a
path where
he might meet up with kim um
but you know what i mean like i if it's
just him getting caught and having do
his time and there's a you know there's
a lot of people out there throughout the
idea like oh he would he would thrive in
in prison
and that would be so great and you know
all of that sounds kind of terrible to
me because i don't want him to continue
to be saul goodman you know that that
seems like a torturous
existence to me um
and and it's not it's not what i want to
see for the character because
for all this faults i i think he's a
sympathetic character so
um the other part of this i guess then
would be kim
i think kim is mostly right in in in
her her her thinking that that
them being together is a bad idea yeah
you know at least how they were at the
time and i think that has to do with the
fact that
even though they were in love and it was
real there was this other part of it
that they were kind of addicted to and
then whenever they you know
when you think about the the trajectory
that they were on
you know that only it's going only going
to escalate you know it wasn't their
fault that that howard got killed um you
know that was that was lalo and you know
that but say that didn't happen
something else bad would have come down
down
eventually you know what i mean they're
gonna keep they're gonna you know
if you if you think back to that like it
was such a masterful
scam like it's on you know like just
think of the different component parts
of the way they set it up and
if walalo doesn't walk into that
apartment they absolutely get away with
it
and so
they're junkies right they get a high
from that
well then you're going to have to do it
again and you're going to have to outdo
yourself you know you can't just go back
and
do a little scam here there at the local
uh you know restaurant bar thing
and get that same feeling you know what
i mean
so i i think kim's right in that you
know that that part of them is is is
over
but depending on what happens to her in
the finale you know it
like i don't think they should end up
together
um but i guess there's in a 70 70 75
minute plus you know episode then there
is possibility that that there could be
some major developments that that change
that
what do you think chase
yeah well i mean i think it's just
ironic thinking about jimmy and kim
having a happy ending especially after
that uh 608 promo that we got during the
mid-season break
uh you know
you know that ended up just being a
throwaway line and i feel like this show
is going to end bittersweet just like
breaking bad did um
and the thing is is i i agree with you i
don't think that uh
they should be together because kim does
realize how they're bad for each other i
do like the idea of let's say
hypothetically if jimmy does uh go to
jail or prison that their final reunion
is maybe kim visiting him in jail or
prison whatever but at the same time if
if gene saw jimmy whatever gets caught
then he might be the witness to you know
make kim's confession actually stand
some ground here so in a way if a gene
gets caught and gets arrested it might
result in kim getting arrested as well
and the thing is is you know at the
beginning of season six throughout the
first half of the of the season i liked
uh the idea of jimmy or gene being able
to thrive as saul goodman in prison more
than i do now sort of being like uh you
know and
within the walls sort of being like a
criminal lawyer in prison similar to uh
shawshank redemption where the main
character i believe uh he's doing like a
bunch of paperwork for not only the
warden but like you know other criminals
that are in there like giving them
advice on what they should say and this
that and a third thing but just the fact
that the end of 609 really
recontextualized the tragedy of saul
goodman as a character you know he's
playing saul because he can't forget
about kim and howard and his past in
general and so he has to distract
himself 24 7 from the moment he wakes up
to the moment he goes to sleep it really
does
prove your point that
saul is just a
a terrible existence to live so i i do
like your idea of uh
of him possibly either coming full
circle back into jimmy or just combining
all of his personas and turning into a
new person in the end i'm not too sure
if he's just gonna get caught or if he's
gonna go down swinging or what the deal
is
the teaser shows or it sounds like gene
is out of breath as if he was running
away but also kind of sounds like he
might be in trouble like he's hurt or
injured or something like that so it it
you know the option for gene to uh to
live or die is still still almost 50 50
for me i'm not sure how he would die
it's not like he's going gonna get into
a huge gun fight or anything like that
uh maybe we'll talk about that more here
uh but yeah i'm not too sure i i think
that it's gonna be bittersweet i would
like for something more to happen than
just gene gets arrested and that's that
i mean we have an extended episode here
for the finale so i assume a lot's gonna
happen uh but yeah i guess we'll just
have to wait and see here it's only in a
few days and then i'm i'm almost in
denial that we're at that we're at the
end here you know if i feel like it's
not going to be until like a week after
the finale airs that we don't get a new
episode that it finally kind of clicks
i'm like wow that really you know
really was the ending you know i don't
know i feel like i'm in denial for the
show being over but the same time it's
been quite a ride i'm looking forward to
it
yeah i remember you know the breaking
bad um
you know when it when it ended and
i wasn't nearly i mean i was i was a
huge fan i was um
you know it was water cooler tv so it
was something that was always
in the conversation just like
in regular you know
in my regular life day-to-day life but i
wasn't
you know i wasn't looking at it in the
same way that i'm that i've been
kind of invested in this so um
yeah it is it is kind of wild that it
it's it's all going to finish up in just
a couple days um
i i think denial is kind of where i'm at
you know like i'm i haven't given myself
the chance to um
let it set in yet
french
but yeah and you touched on a lot of
things that i think will come back to um
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna uh and you
know
reply to all of them at the right the
second because i think that we'll we'll
we'll come back around but
uh you know i i i i i'm following where
you're going with that right now like it
it's um
i think we're we're
pretty close and and where we're we're
thinking it's gonna happen but i mean
that you bring up that idea of 70
minutes it's like uh that's a super long
episode of better call saul you know i
mean
we've never seen anything like that in
in this universe like that's almost
that's closer to
the run time of a feature than it is to
to one of these episodes so there's a
lot of room for them to
do do some different things in that
um francesco foddy thank you for the one
euro 99 do you think we'll see a chuck
flashback and this is why i didn't uh
initial you know want to respond to
everything you were saying there because
i saw this question
and this is something that i have been
i've been warming up to a lot over the
last couple of days
nice
i think there's a real possibility this
could happen like i don't want to get my
hopes up too high because it's
complicated to bring you know somebody
in somebody like this in for just one
episode especially during the pandemic
and everything else
but you know i was thinking about how
they went to great lengths to to
keep
walt and jesse coming back a secret
until they just decided not to do that
anymore you know
and and peter gould said yeah we thought
we would just let let fans know and and
get it out there because it's there's
it's not the most shocking thing we're
gonna do or something along those lines
or they had a lot more um
up their sleeve and i i don't know i
just think about like if you think about
jimmy you know if you think about
not not about saul and where he goes
after 609 but if you just think about
how we got to the place
where that happened
i mean
you kind of have to have
you kind of have to have something that
loops back to chuck and and his
influence over the first half of the
season when you're in the series finale
right
yeah
yeah i definitely agree i mean i've been
really wanting to see a chuck flashback
for
all season long honestly even back in
season five i do kind of i can't
remember if it was michael mckean or
peter gould or someone else that said
this in regards to if they keep bringing
chuck back too much it'll kind of uh you
know
weaken the impact of him dying i think
you might have even told me that at some
point but yeah michael michael mckean
said that he he said if you're if it's a
ghost if a person's a ghost and
they're always around and it takes away
the mystique or something like that you
know that was the general idea
and
and and you know like i've always wanted
more chuck obviously you know i mean
like even whenever he came back in the
next season and and
season four and the finale of that i
mean that was huge you know what i mean
and we've had a couple of years since
that happened
but i i guess in the last couple days
what i'm saying is that i've been
thinking that
they have to because they could they
could they could reference him a ton of
different ways without him actually
showing up or having new content but i
guess what the last couple of days what
i've been thinking is that how could
they not
shoot another scene with michael mckean
you know when they're when they're
closing this thing out
i mean and especially ever since howard
died i was thinking oh maybe we'd get a
howard uh flashback in the next episode
especially since that uh teaser showing
kim being sworn in as a lawyer well we
heard it while we just saw the the
candle with howard's blood on it so ever
since that teaser came out i was
thinking well maybe we'll get a
flashback of kim and howard's kind of
standing by side by side uh the same way
that uh chuck uh vouched for uh jimmy to
be sworn in as a lawyer um and i think
that having that flashback with kim and
howard would be a perfect uh excuse to
have chuck show up again but yeah i've
really wanted to see more of chuck
especially ever since i've been
re-watching the show and i've every time
i rewatch the show i grow more and more
appreciation for chuck and i miss him
more and more and i just looked uh i
just watched the 410 uh flashback with
him recently for my season four tier
list and i just loved every little bit
of it i i really i really uh was sad at
the fact that we didn't see him at all
in season five i mean it makes sense uh
and at the same at the same time though
i really want more of chuck i guess i
can always go back and re-watch those
early seasons if we don't get them in
the next episode i won't be disappointed
or too disappointed i'll be a little bit
sad but you know i can live without it
but if we do see it especially with the
fact that they haven't like spoiled it
like the way that it did with the walton
jesse cameos i think it'll be amazing
i'll be i'll be freaking out that's for
sure
yeah and you know we have a situation
where they're jumping back and forth in
timelines anyways you know what i mean
it's not it wouldn't be out of place
and and that was sort of what i was kind
of thinking before was like how many
flashbacks could they do or you know
maybe it's maybe it's too much or you
know but i mean we're jumping all over
the place already we're going in and out
of uh of the different timelines because
you know obviously i also have wanted to
see you know another
flashback to kim's past too you know so
you have those two ideas competing like
well there's only one cold open there's
only one flash forward but i mean we're
we can move anywhere in the timeline
pretty much you know i mean it's not
like they're they're they're uh
doing this completely linearly linear
linearly why can't i say that word right
now in a linear fashion
heen thank you for the 499. number one
in burned lab hass hank asks where the
two bodies
where were the two bodies two came from
colorful life to black and white walt
about to go from boring black and white
to color
three
pilot song
lyrics um
so the lab thing that that is
uh those the two bodies that they're
referring to there are the two guards
that they killed before they burned it
down so
that that's not related to the bodies
that are buried underneath
um kim colorful life to black and white
walt about to go from boring black and
white to color yeah there's a you know
there's there's certainly um
some uh
there's that there's certainly
there there's those are two different
directions that both those characters go
in without a doubt
and then number three i'm not sure i
understand pilot song lyrics kim i'm not
sure pilot
song
um
like the song from like the pilot
episode like the first episode of the
show ever
yeah that's what i'm not understanding
like i was thinking maybe he was talking
about the extended version of the
of the theme song but that's not what it
says
i'm not too sure honestly
yeah i i can't really i can't really
comment on that because i don't i'm not
sure
i i'm i'm trying to think of the pilot
like oh address unknown that's the
opening of uh the pilot right oh yeah i
was i was i was thinking the better call
saw timeline but yeah i guess every gene
timeline or gene scene
yeah
and then um
that's is that the one where the
i'm not sure i haven't listened to that
while but um
if they did add that i mean they didn't
know it at the time when they put it in
there but i wouldn't be surprised if
they if they you know if they pulled on
that
later at when they mined things you know
what i mean to to uh develop the story
later on
okay let's see
you go ahead if you have something on
that
oh it's just the lyrics are kind of like
what i'd give to see the face of you
i shouldn't have stayed away from you so
long
um should have known one day you'd be
gone
so maybe he's talking about kind of you
know kim wanting to see gene again but
i'm not too sure that that's the
interpretation i i got entirely from uh
from watching 612 um again you know kim
was really caught off guard when gene
called her so that could be why
but i i do i do definitely love the
lyrics to that to that song i really
love think spots definitely a big fan
yeah that's a cool tune um yeah and i
agree i don't think that um
she she's wanting to see him but
the other way around he he obviously is
i think that that's one of the big
takeaways from
612 is that
where he's at he's doing all this stuff
to try to
you know
just
make him make his existence a little a
little bit more bearable but he's he's
obviously like that's the the main thing
that's not that's on his mind you know
you see him break during the phone call
and you see her almost
break in response and um you know she
shuts it down because she doesn't want
to go
there
i made his army thank you for the one
pound 79.
if it's a trial i expect to see
skylar marie and flynn
yeah um
there's this you know there's a lot of
people that would like to see this show
turn into
a courtroom drama in the last episode
and um
you know
i i i really kind of hate the idea or i
did you know what i mean um
when i was thinking about it and and
this is this is why i don't like it i
guess i i don't know if i've really laid
that out i can't remember if we talked
about this in the last stream but i
don't think i have in any of my
my main videos the thing about it is
that
the way that things are structured the
way that they set things up they're
building towards this
you know they've been they've been
they've been building towards this big
release right um
of when
he'll either
face his face all this stuff that is is
pushing him in the direction that's
leading him down all these into all
these bad choices and and
all this calamity that that he's been
experiencing for the few years since you
know six years or whatever since kim
left um
you know they've been they made they
took him to the darkest place they could
i mean he was going to
choke out and possibly murder
uh carol burnett you know
so like
there's a release in that
there's a release coming one way or the
other right um so
i i feel like it would be
i feel like you sort of be backtracking
if you if you had that and then you have
a big long drawn out
courtroom scene now i do think he you
know he's probably going to turn himself
in or he might get caught
i feel like turning himself in is a lot
more satisfying because then he makes
the decision
i mean he could get caught and then make
the decision after the fact but
you know i i
if it's a i guess to to just bring it
back a little bit to what the question's
saying
if it is a trial i don't expect to see
too much of it
in this last part of the you know of the
story
um
i think it does set up a situation where
he could see kim face to face again
whether if it's in the courtroom or if
it's if if he's not in custody he could
see her
outside uh she was there's definitely a
possibility that she'd be called to
testify or she could you know
end up having her own
situation uh with with the court um
but i mean
to what you're saying it would make
sense for skyler to be
to be involved possibly in the actual
trial itself because she knows
what he did with
uh walter i guess
the other thing kind of and i don't know
if this really matters as much as it is
it seems like it does in my head but
for people who never saw breaking bad
um
you know
does it make sense to have a conclusion
to to or or to like relitigate what he
does in that series
in this one you know what i mean that's
a lot of stuff that they didn't they
haven't really shown that much from you
know
the saul timeline in in this particular
television show
so yeah i don't know what do you think
do you do how do you feel about
a a detailed trial and do you think that
we could see skyler marie and flynn
i mean i would like to see skylar again
i i honestly don't think that we will
it'd be really cool i think that the you
know sentence kind of where francesca
gives a nod to her in 611 might be all
that we really get
um
in regards to like a huge court scene i
think you have said in previous streams
where it's not really necessary and i
kind of have to agree with that i mean
back in between seasons five and six i
really like the idea of
gene and kim having a reunion maybe kim
helps him out with jeff or something
like that or if gene does get arrested
then kim can uh represent him in a
similar way that uh to season three but
with you know kim giving up her her
career in the law i i don't think that
she's gonna go back to that i mean i
guess it is technically possible to be
reinstated uh but i don't know i've seen
a lot of comments about saying how kim's
gonna come back and be be his lawyer and
i just don't see that happening honestly
it's kind of the same thing how we were
saying earlier if you see chuck too many
times it kind of weakens the impact of
his death while if suddenly kim comes
back as a lawyer that'll weaken the
impact of of her giving up that career
and just everything that it's meant
since then uh and so yeah i think that
if if gene gets arrested i think we can
kind of skip over the court scene i mean
we we know that the show can do a good
job doing having a court you know drama
episode like chicane read one of the
best episodes of all time yeah i i just
i just don't think it's a it's
incredibly necessary here i think it'd
be cool to see marie however if we did i
think that that would be with a hank
cameo and i don't think we're gonna see
hank again sadly and then in regards to
flynn i mean uh just actors aging i mean
i guess that hasn't really been an issue
for the show beforehand they've kind of
they've kind of given up on that you
know but i don't know i feel like
flynn's actor might be a little bit too
old here
in that regard
yeah i i yeah i mean i don't know i
would be open to seeing
anything if they if they if they did it
you know you know in the right way i i
just i would um
i i would think you know like you you
you brought up chicanery and that really
is one of the best episodes i mean that
certainly was before
um my favorite episode and and it's one
of those it's kind of like i don't know
it's kind of i remember the first time i
saw that one it's sort of like the same
time you know the first time i saw the
red wedding and um
game of thrones you know what i mean it
was just sort of like
oh god
you know i mean it just sort of just
like it just stuck with you for so long
after you saw it and and that was the
thing you know that character needed to
be
he needed to be
in that arena exact you know
specifically he needed to be
brought down in that way
and i just don't really
i don't see that that's not what i want
for jimmy at least do you know what i
mean like i i want him to make this
decision himself and i and i think on
some level that's part of kim's
motivation too because like he said she
could help him
on the phone she could have you know she
could have talked sense into him he
would listen to her you know what i mean
but i feel like there's at least a part
of her that's saying you know i don't
want to make this decision for you i
want you to actually
get there yourself because then it means
something you know what i mean
yeah
so uh
yeah like
i i i absolutely agree skyler would be a
great cameo and i've seen a lot of
people bring that up in the comments of
my last couple videos
um
but
you know they'd have to do it in a way
that it wasn't just like oh look there's
skyler on the other side of the the
courtroom you know they'd have to kind
of try to make her
an important part of what's happening
and i'm not sure they're going in that
direction you know
and you know one of the things that i
saw often repeated about the whole court
is that it started out in the courtroom
it has to end in the courtroom or it
should return and i and i agree that you
know there there should be some sort of
justice
i just think that um
you know if
i'm looking forward to like seeing
the conversation that jimmy and kim
have
in relation to them
having to be there you know i mean or
something like that a lot more than i'm
thinking about like i definitely don't
want his i don't i definitely don't want
to see something like him
you know defending himself or you know
scamming or pulling something off i mean
that would be kind of antithetical to
what i'm hoping to see as far as how his
story ends you know well i mean i mean
in regards to everything that saul
goodman's done in the events of breaking
bad i mean everything's kind of out on
the table right like everyone kind of
publicly knows what happened it's not a
matter of fact of oh is gene going to be
able to to con his way out of this like
there's no conning his like he's going
to get sentenced you know like it's not
like he's going to get off scot-free
so just what are we going to debate how
much time he's going to do uh i just
don't really see the point of an outcome
of having a court scene because
he's gonna get sentenced regardless you
know maybe it just it's up in the air as
to how long but i don't really think
that's an important detail or too
important
i would like to see you know the dynamic
between him and kim in regards to having
to you know confess or be a witness but
that's a that's a whole other story i
think there's a lot of potential there
but
i think i think that they that the
actual court scene itself isn't really
what they focus on because i don't
really think they're going to do any
conning or scheming in regards to it'll
just be a straight up you did this
you're caught now you're going to prison
yeah like if they were going to go in
that direction then
just have him have him escape and and
get away with it and just keep going
forever and make it like you know
make it
make it a morality tale of like you know
what people never really can change
sometimes or whatever
ravencien thank you for the ten dollars
canadian is there anything redeeming
about this universe nacho's dad
i need any goodness in jimmy and kim to
find a home or some deeper clarity
about what went wrong
um
is there anything redeeming about this
universe uh well i mean
this universe is not
i think what i find compelling about it
is that it's a lot like the one that
it's it's it's not that much different
than than the real world um
you know sometimes good thing or
sometimes bad things happen to good
people
but you know the other
there's usually some
consequences to the characters choices
and and what they're doing so
i guess the question you know to
change the question a little bit is that
um
because i mean you bring up nachos dad
that there's nothing great about or
redeeming about his story i mean he
you know he was he was on the end he was
on the outside he was
you know he had to deal with those
unintended consequences of
the things that happened in that
lifestyle you know what i mean and um
he was a good character he was a
he's he's probably one of the more moral
out of of of the ones that we've met
um
but you know it it
in the end he kind of just plays a part
to to point out you know mike's
hypocrisy or the way that mike kind of
lies to himself and and and the sadness
that goes along with him you know
knowing his existence is that way i mean
you have two two fathers there
they both lost the son they both uh you
know
deal with that in different ways but
nothing
nothing really goes nothing really
happens to make you know
to make up for that
and um so you say you need any goodness
in jimmy and kim to find a home or some
deeper clarity about what went wrong
and yeah i mean that's i think that's
what we're supposed to want and what
that's what we're supposed to be
thinking about right now is that
after watching for the last
handful of episodes how
how
dastardly
gene turned out to be
and and the direction he was going in
before um
you know he went too far
you know
if there's something inside there if
there's any goodness inside then we need
to see that it comes out and um
that's what we're all hoping for
well i mean i mean the thing is with
their characters is is if you do a
little bit of good and then a lot of bad
and then just a little bit of good and a
lot of bad i mean they're not really
evening it out right it's not really a
yin-ying situation like they are good
characters but at the same time they're
both horrible people and i i think they
know what happened and what went wrong
and it's just too many words to to
summarize especially in between each
other and that that's why you know i
mean i guess i guess jessie was a
complete stranger to kim but and so she
wouldn't want to open up about
everything she knows about saul but
you know they they seem to like to keep
thing she likes to keep things too uh to
as few words as possible like when i
knew him he was or
telling gene herself i'm happy that
you're alive uh there's just so many
rabbit holes they could go down to into
well what if this happened or what if
that happened or this was the breaking
point that was the breaking point i mean
there's been so many moments throughout
the series where you think they're gonna
break up and then they don't
um
you know at the beginning of season two
or during after the kashatakan or
when kim finds out about the [ __ ]
cobbler or the
wexler versus goodman and then they get
married and and there's so many and then
you know the season five finale am i bad
for you there's so many times where you
think they're gonna break up and they
don't um and they honestly probably
should have their relationship has gone
on for far longer than any of us have
thought and it just ended with such an
explosive ending um that i think they
know what went wrong and that's that's
what
has been holding on to them
uh
throughout throughout all these years
uh in regards to anything redeeming
about this universe i mean not a lot of
characters are redeeming i mean if
you're listing off nachos dad as a as an
example of a good character then i mean
yeah sure i think that cliff is a good
character i think that rich is a good
character you know they're all good
people
uh the thing is is the this show is this
universe is very heavy on karma
in the sense of what comes around goes
around people always get their
comeuppance uh that doesn't always
happen in real life uh as much as i i
you know hope that it would but
in this show it always seems to go down
that way so
i i'm not sure i'm not sure if they're
gonna be able to fully redeem themselves
and come out with a more of a happy
sort of bittersweet ending maybe kim
because she wants to turn herself in um
but then again kim
turning herself in is kind of selfish i
mean it it relates back to the way that
she accused howard of coming and talking
to jimmy after chuck's funeral where kim
told howard that he just unloaded his
guilt onto jimmy to make himself feel
better well kim is being kind of a
hypocrite here in 612 at least in my
opinion you know it's up to
interpretation but that's at least what
i got from it where she's acting like
she wants to turn herself in because
she's trying to do the noble thing and
she's been thinking about it for so long
but it's just too little too late and
and i don't know i feel like she's being
a bit hypocritical where she's doing
what she accused howard of in uh in
season four so i i would just like to to
see if anything comes of that i i i want
that to make everything come full circle
though i really do like how cheryl
doesn't give her the satisfaction that
she's looking for in the same way that
nacho's dad doesn't give mike the
satisfaction he was looking for in
regards to them confessing what happened
uh to their loved ones and i really like
that parallel there because it does seem
kind of selfish of mike and kim to uh
to come to these people because it's
it's the same thing as uh kim saying to
howard all who cares what jimmy feels as
long as howard feels good and and it's
funny because that was never howard's
intention but i do think that this is
kim's intention uh whether she openly
even realizes what she's doing or not
um
i don't know i just really like that
parallel sorry another rabbit hole
yeah yeah
i can't say that i agree with that there
um
i i
i mean i i i kind of understand the i
kind of understand the
the
the
inclination of i mean i kind of see how
you got there but
um and i don't want to completely uh i
don't want to completely derail it just
i think that
i don't think her motivation was to make
herself feel better um
and yeah i think i'll just i think we
can just leave it there because i think
it'll it'll come back up again but um
i i see what you're saying and i thought
i thought the same thing when i thought
about it
before it happened but i guess watching
it play out in the in the way that it
did you know i i um
i wouldn't necessarily agree it doesn't
mean that it's wrong you know it's a
it's a it's an interpretation but
exactly
exactly that's completely fine you know
that's the whole point of this show
right this whole point of entertainment
to interpret things how you see and
that's why i love discussing this show
because there's so many like it was
chucking the right was jimmy in the
right um it's just what i got from from
the episode if it's not what you got
that's completely fine too uh just
personally for me i just noticed that
parallel and uh couldn't help but uh
kind of latch onto it
yeah yeah and like that i think we'll
probably delve into that a little bit
more as we go because there's a there's
there's definitely more to talk about
with kim um
because of the fact that you know we
know she's going to be in the final
episode it kind of felt like there was
an ending
just like you know they've done several
times in this final run where they they
bring a character to the end and then
you know we know they're going to come
back again so where do they go next um
so yeah i think we'll talk about that as
we go here robert gay thank you for the
4.99 thank you for fostering a
thoughtful community i'll miss bcs and
the fans what has this show brought to
your life that you'll appreciate going
forward
ah that's a
that's a tough question that's a deep
question
yeah
um
i'm trying to think about specifically i
mean i think what what i like about this
show is
is uh
it isn't really unique to this show i i
think that that this show just does
so many things so well
you know simultaneously you know it has
you know the with the way it looks the
way the writing
um
the way that uh the characters are
complicated and they they aren't you
know
you can't it's not easy to figure out
how they're gonna go because they act
like real people you know um
i mean that's not unique to this show
but i think if if i had to say you know
that it has brought
i guess a deeper appreciation for
complicated characters i guess would be
um where it's at i mean you had with
walt you know you had the the anti-hero
that
you know so many other shows picked up
on at that same time um
i mean you already had tony soprano uh
you know these guys were these guys were
uh
they weren't sympathetic really you know
they they had a something that they had
they had a hook in the beginning that
made you think they might be
but they showed themselves to to not be
that way and um
as far as you know the characters here
they they've done bad things and
you know you could even say that they're
bad people i you know but it doesn't
they're a lot more complicated and
interesting
and i think that's my favorite thing
about uh about this show
well the the thing about better call
saul compared to breaking bad is
breaking bad was always on more of a
grandiose scale the stakes were always
higher it was always
you know life and death situations and
how are they going to get out of this
situation what's going to happen who's
going to die but the thing about better
call solids it's even more of a slow
burn than breaking bad but it's way more
down to earth it's way more relatable
and it's way more of a character study
and that's what i really like about this
show the show really focuses on the
characters not to say that breaking bad
didn't you know obviously one of the
best shows of all time but i just think
that better call saul did it even more
so and the fact that they focus so much
on characters and the fact that it's
more day-to-day life situations is what
makes it more relatable and through
watching the show there's so many things
that i can relate to um
you know maybe maybe better call saul is
a bit more hyperbolic in regards to the
situations but
um i just really love how relatable this
show is in so many different uh aspects
of the way that characters act the way
that they actually would in real life
and you know bad things happen to good
people you know the way that karma comes
around and
the way that people handle certain
situations and compartmentalize it or
face the facts i don't know i could like
that's like a whole
uh analysis retrospective uh
to
just to really pinpoint what the show
has uh
brought to us in regards to how we
appreciate life in regards to just
appreciating television i mean this show
is so brilliant i feel like it's almost
ruined uh ruined tv for me um you know
just set the bar so high it's hard to
find another show like that i mean there
are other shows you know severance is a
really good one which i'm glad you
introduced me to an absolute banger um
but
yeah i don't know i don't know it
definitely definitely just uh definitely
just such a good show that it's going to
be hard to find another one like that
in the future
yeah there's going to be a there's going
to be a void and that's going to be
tough to fill i guess uh you know
let's see here big ralph too thank you
for the two 603 blew me away from the
open to the very end that's absolutely
true i would agree with that 100 percent
um
it's just not the only one that did that
in this season you know and and it's
funny
we were talking about that in the in the
last stream uh
i had seen
you know gill brought up that he had
someone brought up asked him you know
like can you believe that
603 nacho's death was in the same season
because it doesn't even seem like it
anymore you know like think about how
much has happened since then
i know right it feels like it was so
long ago and the thing is is when that
episode came out and not the nacho death
happened we were like we still have 10
whole episodes left like what is gonna
happen and now that we're here it's like
wow like so much really has happened it
is kind of crazy
yeah a lot a lot was the answer to that
you know
um
but yeah i i it'll be it it'll be
interesting after it's all said and done
to to look at it i've never really been
big on on
rankings and things like that just
because i'm
i i get i get so caught up in things
that are happening at the moment that
you know i mean i'm always like
oh okay that one was the best you know
yeah there definitely is recency bias
and all that and also like every time
you re-watch the show you find a new
appreciation for it so what might be
your top five favorite episodes right
now a year from now that could
completely change and etc down down the
road
yeah
let's see jorge farah thank you for the
ars
500 um
that's that's a pink one so or a magenta
one so that means that it's a very
generous amount um i can't say for sure
i'm not familiar with the currency but
but thank you for that
um i used to think bcs jimmy
and breaking bad saul were
irreconcilably different casual sexism
um
you're killing me with that booty
casually suggesting murder etc
season six's biggest accomplishment for
me is that it managed to make the
transition convincing agree disagree
uh yeah i would agree um those things
all kind of stood out to me
um
and i mean if you think about it i was
watching eric's stream last night um
or you know my morning but night time
for everybody else they were you know
they
bob and ray were on there he interviewed
them and
um you know they were
bob said it really plainly
you know that jimmy is who he who he
really is
that's when he's being himself and
when we see saul
that's an act
you know that that it's not just
it's not just a thing that happened but
it's also a thing that he actively
participates in is putting up that front
and i think it's a it's an under
appreciated part of the last episode
how he sits there for like an hour
before he lets kim come in and sign the
papers because
he has to to act as cruel and and just
unaffected as he tries to do in that
conversation when he tells her you know
have a nice life and and won't let her
get a word in
that's
he has to he has to he has to put that
front up you know i mean he it's
he i mean he's he's the it the show did
make the transition make sense um you
know with that with that jump to the
flash forward
when we see him we know it's connected
to that we know it's a reaction to that
i really love that because it opens the
door and you know you mentioned casually
suggesting murder that's the thing that
people threw out a lot you know it was
like well how he he's totally okay with
them killing people
i mean it you know
he does he does suggest it but if you
think about it through that that that
he's he's
he's he's putting on an act and he's and
and not that he isn't affected and not
that he isn't um
much different in that persona but i'm
just saying that like you know
he may be he may be looking at the
situation and thinking these people
aren't going to kill anybody so it
doesn't matter what i say if i say it
and it is something that
um you know
gets me to where i'm trying to go in
this conversation
then you know that's a lot different
than actually thinking you know actually
it's like taking part in making those
things happen
right i mean i think there's there's a
pretty pretty clear line there
but yeah you know i i think that
the way they did it it was surprising
and i really liked it at the time
because you know
obviously that was the joke always you
know people saying oh that was the
moment that he turned into
saul goodman
because you know people said that
earnestly for so long about every single
thing that happened that eventually it
just became completely a joke but they
but they actually did pull that off you
know
the breakup was the thing that forced
him to
um
use this coping mess mechanism and when
he's in that mode then yeah all of that
other stuff makes sense you know he he
may not
he doesn't have to be that way all the
time but but it certainly fits inside
what what he's capable of
yeah yeah i definitely agree and in
regards to the casual sexism i mean i
remember how the
the scene of uh saul kind of cat calling
francesca in breaking bad 208 and trying
to make an advance on her even if he was
joking this sort of like hey how about i
follow you home oh you're killing me
with that booty i mean we all thought
that that was one of the biggest plot
holes of the show of of um
just in regards to jimmy's character and
better call saul especially before we
knew what happened to kim if he was
still with her in breaking bad or not or
if not you know how that actually went
down
but and i remember the creators saying
multiple times that they actually hate
how they included that line you know
it's just a throwaway throwaway line and
breaking bad but now they had to
actually work around it and they you
know if they could go back they would
just delete that line and never have it
be a thing in general but they actually
did successfully
come full circle and show how
saul is like that
and i do agree that he's putting on a
front and it's just an act uh in regards
to saul goodman and it's in his persona
um you know he calls francesca's sweet
cheeks in front of kim trying to again
hide his emotions and pretend that he
doesn't care when really he does uh and
the thing is with uh with that 208
breaking bad scene there's no one else
there right it's just him it's just
francesca it's like who is he putting on
this play for and plus francesca even
knew who he was as jimmy back in better
call saul season three so it's not like
he's fooling anyone but he is trying to
convince himself as much as he is trying
to convince anyone else and i i really
love that um i love how they uh you know
i don't i don't like the way he treats
francesca but i love how they made that
made sense because that was one of the
biggest questions it funny it's funny
calling it a big question but it was it
was a huge concern how they were gonna
make that make sense uh and they
actually did and i think that that's
really cool how
i don't know it was just such an issue
within the fandom uh and and they worked
it out i mean bravo right
yeah absolutely yeah i like the um you
know the
the little reference to it in the last
episode like if he would say that in
front of kim you know
it's the perfect timing because you know
it shows that he's just you know he's
just he's just trying to
uh you know
he's trying to just keep up the front
you know that's all it is
dan ny thank you for the 499 theory
saul escapes omaha then after a time
jump he discovers kim's in jail this
compels him to finally overcome his
alter egos and turn himself in
i mean there's a possibility that that
could it could play out like that i i
guess where you know where i don't like
it is that
he's doing this because
it would help
kim
rather than doing it for himself
because that's what i really want to see
i feel like that's what's what's leading
that's what's underneath all of
all of this destruction that's happening
is his inability to to look at those
things and and move past them and and
you know this would
this would get him there
but for me at least i think it's a lot
more satisfying if he gets to that that
answer himself rather than being forced
to you know
well see see the thing is i think i
think that
what's gonna happen is if if they one or
both of them went to jail right i think
what's gonna happen is backwards to what
this is saying i think that
gene getting arrested and going to jail
is what's going to cause kim to possibly
get arrested too because he's gonna be
the the witness or whatever uh because
you know kim told cheryl that there's no
evidence uh aside from maybe her
ex-husband if he's even alive um
and then also in regards to turning
himself in um i think that
i i don't know because the phone call
really broke both of them and made them
both snap in different ways uh the phone
call between kim and jean in 612 and
where kim actually wants to turn herself
in i feel like
gene or jimmy wants to but he can't
after everything he went through going
into hiding his gene all the effort he
put into that but he's being
self-destructive right so he's purposely
pushing the envelope uh
with all these cons with jeff and buddy
and then hitting that last mark of the
guy that had cancer and then even going
back into the house instead of escaping
and stealing the watches and everything
keeps pushing and pushing until he he is
going to get caught and it's almost like
he wants to get caught but just
his way of getting caught is different
than kim and it seems like they deep
down both want the same thing except
where kim just outright
wants to turn herself in gene wants to
go down swinging almost so i i like how
they're kind of working towards the same
ending but just in completely different
ways
yeah i i think what what kim i guess
to go back to circle around i i think
what kim
wants is to make it right
i don't think jimmy can even look at it
yet you know what i mean
i don't know that i don't know
i don't know
sorry uh
i don't know that that character you
know the
the where he's g you know where he's at
in his his ex existence as gene there
i'm not even sure that he
can imagine what making it right might
look like you know like would turning
himself in and actually make it right
not really you know what i mean
whereas because
you know kim hasn't spent the last six
years
working
you know working for
meth kingpins and things like that and
and even beyond that just you know just
purposely
uh you know corrupting
the the process of of the law to get
people who are obviously guilty off you
know what i mean
yeah
you know they're they're in two very
different places as far as um
you know where
what the what that what the what their
actions you know what makes sense for
them to do in in
in their actions or whatever um
yeah it's fascinating
because
gene
if you think about like
he's you know he's in he's in survival
mode he i don't i don't expect him to
snap out of that you know
lightly yeah
he's been running you know he he's he's
he's a scammer he's he he's all the
things that we know about him and we and
he reacts to
he's going to react to this situation in
that way you know what i mean like he's
not going to just he had a moment where
jimmy came back out with marion at the
end
and
i i assume that he's going going to
change as a result of that but i don't
think it's going to be like a light
switch you know he's still he's
nobody just
if you know the police are after you
you're a wanted
criminal
your survival instinct is gonna kick in
and you're gonna have to you know you're
gonna have to override that at some
point like it's not just gonna come
naturally that oh yeah you know what
this was all a big mistake let's let's
make this right
and even if you did want to make it
right you know just referencing what
mike told jesse in that breaking bad
missing scene during el camino that's
the one thing you can never do almost
wish that mike could have somehow told
kim that uh because you know she clearly
doesn't realize that she's trying to
make things right but cheryl just tell
like you've ruined his reputation you've
ruined his legacy you practically got
him killed even if you're not the one
that pulled the trigger like there's
nothing you can do to make this right
it's the same thing and maybe that's why
mike realized that with uh nacho's dad
you know trying to go and make things
right with him obviously that didn't
work out so i almost wish that kim could
hear mike's advice that he told jesse
and el camino because that's very much
uh what we're seeing here
yeah joe lucy thank you for the 9.99 you
all made this ride even more special
thank you
they say the ending will be unlike
anything we have seen
could it be as controversial confusing
to viewers as sopranos similar ambiguity
um
yeah well thank you for the kind words
and
i i think i touched on this earlier in
the when we first opened but yeah they
say it's unlike anything
and i i don't really know what to make
of that
you know there's only so many ways that
they can end the story and
it's almost hard to imagine that they
came up with something that is is is
like very specifically different than
something you know anything we've ever
seen
so i'm trying to not give that too much
weight
um
as far as being controversial confusing
as sopranos like i remember watching
um
like the sopranos was one of those shows
that
it was out in a time whenever like not
even everyone
had hbo you know what i mean so like you
would watch
i watched it anyways with with friends
almost always you know like we got
together and
and we all watch the episodes they
happen so my experience with that finale
was
you know i it was it was in a group
where a lot of different people were
were
you know we had we had a conversation
that lasted a long time after it
happened i don't know
i don't know i i remember the
it's sort of but it's sort of in the
time before like you know
hot takes were
as prevalent as they are now so i don't
really know i mean i know that some
people didn't like it
it was ambiguous um
i think in in retrospect i mean that was
that that's that's a great way to do it
i mean i think it's it's
it it makes it from a storytelling
point of view it makes complete sense
like i can understand why they went
there and and
and i and i
i support the choice
um but
and
now
you know if it happened now like it
would it would it could possibly
because of the way that people
everyone you know is gonna would publish
their hot take on it and you know
there would be like a whole
media cycle
that
would be driven by
you know that reaction
and you know all the weird stuff that
goes along that with you know with
social media and clicks and everything
else
i don't know i don't know if it would
work as well here because people aren't
going to um
people aren't going to sit back and and
contemplate
and that's just not the way people
watch things anymore unfortunately um
i i think i think i would like ambiguity
um for what it's worth like i would like
to just see that like i'm gonna keep
coming back to these same points you
know i'd like to see him
face what what's going on and and and
make the decision and um you know move
in a direction
towards
being jimmy again you know
but
i don't need to see the the after if i
get that i don't need to see what comes
after you know i mean it's not it's not
nearly as
important um so if that would be similar
in ambiguity
similarly
ambiguous then then i could go for that
i'm not sure how it would be
how people would would take that though
yeah i found some fun i was just
glancing over at the chat and saw
someone say how family guy spoiled
sopranos endings for many people and
that i was actually gonna mention that
because i did see that family guy
episode before i saw sopranos and you
know just to quote stewie at least we're
all like the sopranos cut to black
mid-set
and i was like oh that seems like a
stupid way to end the show but then you
actually go back and watch it and you're
like oh okay like ended up growing a lot
of appreciation for it now i don't think
that better call saul is going to be
ambiguous as that i think that it is
going to leave something open to
interpretation but i do think that we're
going to get a finite like this is where
kim ends up this is where gene ends up
this is their ending that's that um
but also it is it is going to be kind of
kind of weird the way things go down
because i mean the creators have said
that the finale isn't just the last
episode right it's been this last
handful of episodes honestly ever since
609 so we've been seeing the finale this
whole time
um and so the next episode is gonna be
the conclusion but
i don't really i'm not gonna think of it
so much of a finale as i am a conclusion
if that makes sense um yeah
yeah i mean there's a part of me that
thinks that that's what they're
referring to about how
it's different you know what i mean
like because like i said you know i
can't really i can't really
imagine i mean i think it's going to be
pretty straightforward you know what i
mean because that's just the way the
show is it's sort of like
all these big events that happen you
know that they're inevitable but they
make them exciting as hell to watch as
they play out and and still surprising
you know like there's still a chance
that you can even though you know what's
going to happen that you're you know
this that's what the beauty of we talked
about 603 a lot that's the beauty of 603
right is that
you know that every you know where all
the other characters how their stories
end so you know that his ends there but
you can still fight and want to expect
that something that can't happen will
happen and and that's a great that's a
great way to to i mean it's a great
position to be in when you're you're
when you're watching you know
something like that uh play out i mean
it's just it's just it's so cool and
that's what i expect that the finale
will be like too you know i mean um
i don't i don't think they're going to
reinvent uh
you know the the story in a way that
we're we're just shocked but um we'll
see i guess you know they they have said
that and more than once you know there's
there's more than one reference to that
and and almost like there's a little bit
you almost get there's a little bit of
apprehension or a little bit of like
they're worried how it'll be received
which is good because you know you want
to see them take chances because the
reward you know if if they pull it off
the reward is that much better
um radio chaos thank you for the five
dollars canadian it's funny it's funny
no characters in both shows ever ended
up doing serious jail time
maybe jimmy will be the only one to
actually go to prison
he could be
there's there's sense in what you're
saying this is a popular idea of course
and
you know
i i don't
yeah i mean
like i said if he if he does
if he does the things i just talked
about in the last one if he does uh you
know look at
if he does if he is able to make that
change or or at least that just
acknowledge
uh
and be
and be ready to to change if necessary
then being in prison or being free it
doesn't really change that you know that
like it still works
i mean yeah just uh
just for the uh the trifecta of the
three main characters having different
endings right walt dies jesse lives and
runs away and then
gene goes to jail i i like it just for
the simple fact that they all get a
different ending but we'll just have to
wait and see you're kind of kind of
beating a dead horse in regards to gene
going to jail honestly kind of
kind of said everything we can about it
i just have to wait to see if it comes
to fruition or not or if they can uh
you know give us a twist somehow
yeah and um
and it's interesting because you know
that that's sort of what what that sort
of been the the the
the
you know i don't know cookie cutter
response i guess is the three main
characters it's funny because there's
obviously four you know
kim is obviously
maybe
i mean she's at least equal to jessie as
far as her importance in the story and
and maybe even more you know i mean um
sure but they they have a very similar
they have a very similar role and and
you know that they're they're both next
to
the one that's driving the action and um
we don't know what her we don't know how
her ending is going to you know
that
what happens to her will also
uh you know color what how we think
about
how how we feel or think about what
happens with jimmy you know
sucked 199 you think kim gets arrested
and jimmy just escapes
i don't um
they would they would have to really
write the hell out of that to make that
work for me like you know to be
satisfying if anybody could i guess it's
these guys right um
but yeah i mean we kind of touched on
this so i don't wanna i don't wanna
linger here too long
um i don't know
i i just don't see what
how i don't know how you walk away from
that and being like yeah all right i i
can dig it you know jimmy is
jimmy got away and kim
kim kim is in prison that's the way it
should have been that's the way it
should have worked out like i can't see
how you get to that but
it's a valid question i'm not i'm not
putting down the idea of thinking about
it because it's a possibility it really
is harrison wade thank you for the two
pound uh remember jimmy ford's ids in
high school
um yeah i mean
and the other thing is is that he knows
he's been working with someone in the um
that for the the
identity theft scam but you know like i
like i said they've they showed really
early maybe in the first episode that he
has a panamanian passport so i think if
he wanted to run they could definitely
make that
happen you know it wouldn't be a big
stretch
just based on the stuff that we already
have um but like we were talking about
at the beginning
we don't know what the timetable will be
or
where his head's at
so it's really hard to speculate on that
oh yeah maybe go ahead oh sorry guys
i was just thinking um
well he's he's kind of sold all the
identities that he's stolen right but he
never sold the identity of that last
mark so it is kind of a thought that
went through my head well what if he
uses that i that last identity from that
final mark and uses that to uh change
his identity but again if he already has
one in his back pocket from beforehand
then uh he might just use that one that
he already has but i think that'd be
interesting if he uh swapped his
identity for uh for that final mark
yeah i mean he's you know he's obviously
working with a guy who who is providing
a service of selling identities you know
what i mean like they sell that
you know they get the money
the him and jeff and buddy are getting
the money for each one of those from
someone who obviously
you know would be a guy to talk about if
you needed to
change your name and disappear
dskcgaming
thank you for the two dollars so kim
didn't tell them about jimmy reaching
out
um
kim didn't tell them
oh i guess
when she went to give the affidavit no
she and she definitely covered it up
whenever she um
whenever she was talking to cheryl and
the idea there is that she's protecting
him because that's what she's always
done we've seen
numerous instances of her
protecting jimmy um throughout the
series
i guess most recently when it was
susannah erickson in season six um
whenever she was in the in her office
i think that's the last time
that she just blatantly
went into uh
protection mode but
you know what i'm wondering is if she's
there's also that other
there's another layer of her trying to
you know hoping against hope that that
you know she doesn't make this if she
doesn't make this decision for him
that you know he he can he can make it
and can change because
i mean she could just call the cops on
on him if she wanted to you know i mean
like
if that was her intention was to get him
in trouble
that would not be difficult at all
so
i guess it's just like what is the
motivation is she trying to to is she
trying to keep him safe because that's
what she thinks is best or
is it something deeper
well i do i do think it's one of those
situations where no matter how long they
go without speaking or how much time
passes that they still care about each
other and i do like the idea that kim is
leaving it up to him to make that
decision on his own especially since kim
has always always had so much pride in
making her own decisions
as well and it's really interesting
seeing that after so long of kim being
passive and living in florida that this
is the first you know decision that
she's really made in so long and it's a
huge one and i think that even though
she told jimmy or jean whatever to uh to
turn himself in that she wants him to
to make that decision on his own
i'm not sure if she's hoping that he
doesn't because then it means that she
won't actually go to jail or if she's
hoping that he does because then he'll
be
the witness to her confession um but i
do like the parallel of her telling
cheryl you know if my ex-husband's even
alive directly relating back to her
telling gene i'm glad you're alive so
she definitely is covering up for him
and uh i love that call back there and
within the same episode
yeah
yeah
uh eric meredith
thank you for the 10. do you think jimmy
gene saul
seeing kim get sentenced to go to prison
would be worse of a punishment for him
than going himself
i just have a feeling he wouldn't be
afraid and could even thrive um
yeah that i mean
who he is right now or who he was when
he was saul goodman
no problem i mean prison is terrible
it's it's an inhumane uh
travesty of of
you know
civilization you know i mean it's it's
there's nothing
even if you're thriving in prison
it's not the same you know no one is
happier thriving in prison or you know
than they are
in the in the real world but i mean
yeah you could i could you know you
could totally see that if he if he
remains saul
slash gene and the jimmy part just stays
buried and um
you know he never faces
any of what he's done or and never
becomes a different person
um that does absolutely make sense uh
and even in that
yes i do think that seeing her get
sentenced would be much worse um for him
yeah i i don't know
you know like i don't really know what
else i can add to that
it's just
there's it's not really a
there's no ques there's no doubt in my
mind that that would be the worst
outcome for him as if she went to prison
yeah yeah i mean uh you know as i said i
don't really know if she's gonna go to
jail before he does i think him going to
jail will cause her to but in the
situation where this does happen
i could see that really hurting him and
him getting you know really sad and
depressed over it but i even wonder if
he could just cut his losses and if he
does somehow manage to get away if he'll
keep running i'm not sure if that would
break him down entirely and cause him to
turn himself in just because he feels
bad or if he'd still stay on the run
even knowing that kim did take a fall
but in a way she did turn herself in so
it may have been what she wanted i i
don't know if that'll give jimmy you
know bring him down the earth the same
way that marion did at the end of the
episode
um but yeah it's a real interesting
thought for sure
yeah
um
i've been thinking a lot about that
about the i trusted you
um
in the in the breaking of the trust
being part of his of his turn
or the part of the thing that kind of
woke him up or whatever we don't really
know because we haven't seen what he
does next but you know the reaction that
we saw that that's definitely happened
in that moment
and um
you know it's a stretch i guess but i i
kind of think i was kind of thinking
about the way that
he felt whenever kim told told him in
609 that that she knew about lalo and
she didn't tell him because i've been
wondering where that that fits in
specifically
and and that was the moment
or the or the part of that whole
situation
where where she broke his trust you know
like
everything else aside
um
he trusted her that they were on on
equal footing that they were that they
were
you know
absolutely uh
in that together
and that and then that situation where
she thought it would be bad for his ptsd
or she thought that
uh he would he would go into the mode of
trying to protect her and that would
throw off the plan that you know was was
important to her at that time
all of that
you know that that's that's part of
that's part of who saul goodman is that
that part
you know that that i guess that
rejection or that that um
or you know that that lie that that that
breaking of their trust there
that that's a part of who he is that's
part of what he's carrying around with
him right
yep yep definitely a good point i i also
really like the parallel of uh
of marion uh being too irene because it
seems where he backpedaled with uh with
breaking irene's trust and trying to get
her friends back he really doubled down
with mary in here um
yeah i don't know it's really there's a
lot of parallels he can make towards it
and i really wonder if he actually does
he actually does care to the point that
well that he broke her trust just
because i think that he did really
genuinely enjoy
um you know spending time with her and
he did think of her as a friend and it
wasn't just a means to an end i do
really like your parallel about kim
lying to him about about lala though i
wonder if that has anything to do with
it
yeah i mean that's really the only thing
i mean obviously he trusted chuck
but i mean there were brothers he knew
that that's who chuck was he wanted
chuck to be someone different you know
and he couldn't get that
it was you know it was an
unobtainable
goal or expectation
so the trust you know like the the
actual choice of that of her saying i
trusted you um
that's the one that's the one place
where i could think that he might he
might have felt felt betrayed was the
fact that kim didn't tell him about
um
lala being alive and
you know that there were some big some
big consequences that happened to that
because of that decision and you know
it's complicated because
yeah mike told her not to worry about it
to live her life and all of that and
then he pulled his guys and whatever but
you know like
between them and and where he's at in
his head um you know that there is a
betrayal there
uh shiva ghosh thank you for the 1999.
he's very uh generous great content
thank you both you're welcome
amazing how g tripped up by showing he
knew about bail in albuquerque a call
back to bag man
lala looms over everything question how
will you see breaking bad differently
after bcs
yeah i hadn't thought about that uh big
uh bail payment in season five that's
that's a nice connection there that it
didn't pop up to me
yeah
oh yeah and also yeah lalo is like a
specter he's he's he's always um
it seems like he'll always be haunting
jimmy
jean
how will i see breaking bad differently
um i mean that's an ongoing thing right
now that's still developing
you know after 609 what i felt like was
i'm gonna see it differently because
this is a really
set has it got a lot sadder um you know
like the fact that he's
he's using the saul goodman persona as a
coping mechanism
um
there's that there's you know mike you
know his character is
is a lot more
tragic if that was even possible you
know
um
but yeah i think that you know if i go
back and do a full series re-watch i'll
be thinking about the motivations a lot
differently um
for everyone that's that's that's
involved in it and and how
how saul
you know kind of is a catalyst for a lot
of things and what that's in response to
yeah that's the thing right sol's the
thing that brings the whole breaking bad
universe together um i definitely see uh
mike's relationship with saul
differently like when you look at the uh
the 611 scene with saul and mike
compared to uh what episode was it i
think it was either half measure
or full measure when mike goes to
saul looking for jesse and he's uh using
that swing master
um
i don't know there's a lot of scenes in
breaking bad that now that we have the
uh the context of better call saul uh
we'll see everything in a different way
i think it definitely makes a tragic
character where he used to just be kind
of a haha you know comedian um
not now it's just now it's just
depressing to think of the ways
and another thing too like the way that
he just kind of
nonchalantly tells walt to get over the
whole if ted situation um clearly that's
just you know again him putting up the
ruse of the casual sexuality and and
everything because
he
he's trying to tell the wall like oh
you're not the only one that's been
through something like that i mean i
guess kim never cheated on him but his
previous wives did with uh with chet or
uh or or his stepdad or whatever that
story was but
it's just another situation of of saul
just trying to uh trying to be casual
trying to pretend like he doesn't care
about when women break his heart when
clearly he does very much so
yeah
just a bit um
joe gabriel acosta thank you for the two
euro ending isn't flashy according to
bob oh thoughts
yeah i remember him saying that early on
in one of the early
articles that came out
um but i think
i i think what he said was it's not you
know a bunch of people shooting guns and
things like that uh but he also said in
that too that there is some action
and so yeah i i assume that
he's talking about the closing moments
specifically when he says
how it goes out and i think that sounds
fitting to me
you know i feel like there there's a lot
of intensity wrapped up in him running
away from marions and i think that we'll
get a climax to all of that
but i imagine you know i mean i think
we're going to see that we're going to
see
a final
we're going to see whatever kim does
after she goes back to florida um
i think that's you know after her cry on
the on the bus
in the airport
she's going to um
be different i don't think she's gonna
totally necessarily
just stop being the person that she was
in florida but you know i feel like
she made the decision
she wasn't making decisions she made the
decision to um give the affidavit
after she talked to to um saul
or jean i guess
and so
i think we'll see what happens with that
and then i think they're going to see
each other again or they're going to at
least talk to each other one more time
on the phone at the very least
and uh yeah then beyond that i don't
really see
how it would go out with the bang um
yeah yeah you pretty much took the words
right out of my mouth i mean i think
we're gonna see a little bit action for
sure with gene trying to escape but uh
yeah i don't think that it's gonna be
like a huge gun fight like uh like
walton the the trunk machine gun or
anything like that it's probably gonna
be more of a slow burn more of a
character study more character
development to conclude out gene and kim
it's not going to go out with a bang so
to speak maybe
maybe you know a heartbreak or two but
uh nothing
nothing
nothing quite like a showdown in in the
same way that breaking bad was
yeah um steve bob jd thank you for the
9.99 do you have any future plans for
your channels after the show ends or is
it too early to think about
well i'll still be doing tv i mean i'm
always doing something um
i
the i'm gonna i mean i'm gonna do house
of the dragon
i'm gonna do something with that um
that's gonna be a really crowded space
and i'm not sure i mean i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna i you know back when i
didn't do this full-time
i
was
game of thrones was one of the
things that that kind of pulled me into
this and um i'm i'm a big
fan of that those books and uh
that tv series for the most part i'm
pretty excited about it uh it's kind of
coming right on the heels of this which
is like the only thing i'm thinking
about right now
um i'm i'm
you know i'm gonna be i think i'm going
to be pretty
invested in that and be doing a lot of
content around house of the dragon but
right now i'm just so focused on how
this episode is going to end and better
call saul that
it's kind of taking up all my my my free
time um
yeah do you have any plans uh chase
yeah i mean that's the thing right
there's a lot of shows that i've wanted
to cover over the course of the past
like six months or so it's just that
better call saul has taken up so much of
my time i mean i would have liked to
talk about stranger things season four
the boys season three um there's there's
definitely a lot of shows that i have on
my radar uh i i'm really excited for the
fallout show to come out whenever that
happens probably not gonna be for
another year year and a half since
they're still they're just filming it
right now
there's definitely a lot of a lot of new
shows that i want to do um i might
casually cover you know the new lord of
the rings show or the new game of
thrones spin-off i haven't read much of
the source material or any really to to
those so it's not really like i could go
as in depth with the with the
predictions and all that but you know
there's some shows that i want to watch
casually as you know a lot of new shows
on my radar that are going to be coming
out in the next year even just new
seasons of shows that i want to cover uh
definitely got me hooked on severance
but even so you know even if i couldn't
or if i didn't have the time to do
stranger things or the boys or whatever
i'd still like to go back and cover
those eventually uh probably gonna do
some sort of channel update once uh
once better call saul ends just to give
people an idea of what's on my radar but
you know there's a lot of my mind for
sure there's a lot of good television
coming out and that has come out and i'd
like to cover new stuff as much as uh
old stuff or stuff that's recently aired
yeah um
i mean i you know it it's funny because
i have the shows that i like
you know that i really like and and
sometimes those aren't popular enough to
really
um
do you know as this is my only form of
income uh and then then there's also the
thing of like when there's multiple
shows that are
coming up
at least for the way that i cover them
and the way that i get into
whatever it is i'm doing like i have to
i i can't
i can't really jump back and forth as
easy like right now i'm trying to finish
up my 4-0 mankind season finale video
and it's sort of like it sort of takes
the whole like um
you know just sort of get out of the one
get out of thinking about one thing and
and switch back to the other
so you know like whenever the new shows
are coming out i sort of have to decide
ahead of time
which one i'm going to focus on you know
to really to really give it the time
that i like to do it and and um
the only thing that i've been thinking
about in the in the near future
is uh as house of the dragon and of
course i'll i'll do 1899
which is from the creators of dark which
is one of my favorite shows
when that comes out but that's just a
bin show on on netflix so it'll just be
like you know maybe one weekend of
excitement and then
everyone will forget about it until
the next
the next season comes out you know
that's the thing with stranger things
with everything coming i mean i guess
they did do the final two episodes or
whatever separately but the thing with
stranger things it all comes out at once
uh
it at least with the boys even though it
is a streaming service um
you know they do once a week same thing
with uh invincible whenever that comes
out be happy to to talk about season two
or whatever for that
um
but yeah it's definitely definitely just
trying to trying to figure out which
shows you want to focus on and what you
want to put your time into because as i
said the law if a lot of shows are
airing out once it's really hard to to
branch out when uh when you're already
covering something so in depth but
there'll always be time in the future
that's oh and uh whenever vince gilligan
has that new show that kind of i know
he's just surfing for people to to yeah
it's going to be a while i think
yeah it's going to be
making but eventually definitely going
to give it a shot
yeah i'll definitely be watching it
sounds pretty cool um
just saying it sounds a little bit more
like x-files than um
the uh breaking bad universe but that's
still cool i mean i would like to see
whatever he comes up with next either
way
andrew thank you for the isk300 thanks
for the great bcs content gonna miss it
yeah i'm gonna miss being able to uh
just hop on whenever i feel like it and
have a
a big live stream with a thousand of you
guys sitting here talking to me i mean i
i appreciate it um i think you know i'm
gonna definitely miss it just as much as
you guys are
doggold uh thank you for the
five dollars australian kim and jesse
meeting reminds me of walt and donald
meeting before jane dies do you think
that jesse kim combo is paralleling
foreshadowing something similar
um
well i mean my take on that scene was
that
they were
kind of showing these two people
you know it's sort of like
that it was it was sort of the final
scene of kim when she you know when she
she leaves
uh you know jimmy
saul's orbit
and and it was before
um
it was before
jesse was corrupted and pulled into
waltz right you know like he he still
hadn't hadn't started
started that journey but they have
pretty similar trajectories so
that's what i thought they were doing
and i think they they've kind of said
that this you know that in
follow-up interviews and things that
that's what they were going for
um
i'm trying to think how
you know her dad
i i see the parallel as far as her dad
meeting walt in the bar
that's what that's what this is
referring to right
yeah yeah yeah yeah so um
yeah i i don't know
i mean there's tragedy
in everybody's future in both of those
scenes but i'm not sure if it goes
deeper than that what do you think
i mean i i wonder if kim will ever
reference jessie in the uh in the fact
of because she she must know how saul
was involved with jessie and walt and
all of that so i i wonder if she's going
to put two and two together and realize
hey that that jesse guy i met him once
outside saul's office i mean they were
complete strangers and they and at least
for the better part of uh six years or i
guess they never see each other again
you know that's the only time they ever
saw each other face to face i do like
the parallel of how
kim helped combo and then met jesse
who's combo's friend and then eventually
dies that is that is really cool um
along with the fact that uh that jesse
said that uh yeah sure he'll keep his
nose clean which he both doesn't
literally because you know he gets into
drugs again and then
ends up dying because of being a drug
dealer um so i really do like that combo
mention and i can see how you could
parallel that to uh to walt meeting uh
jane's father while not you know knowing
the significance of who he was until
afterwards
um yeah
that
yeah i mean i think that's the point huh
you know yeah
he didn't she didn't he he didn't
recognize who he was talking to and and
it goes both ways kind of in this uh kim
and uh
kim and jesse thing um true west
oh i was just i was just gonna say it's
just that with the with the walt and
jane's father thing it's just that that
kind of happens immediately one after
another but with kim it's not for like
five six years
that she you know realizes you know who
jesse was so i'm not sure if she'd even
remember this scene or this moment yeah
smoking it's kind of been
that's what i was thinking when you were
talking it's kind of insignificant i was
thinking at first it was kind of
insignificant maybe she wouldn't i mean
they smoked a cigarette in the rain
after hours when she has something else
on her mind and he's got you know a
beanie on the the mention of combo maybe
you know might plant a seed that's but
it's kind of inconsequential compared to
the time frame of what happens with uh
walt in the other situation you're
absolutely correct true west thank you
for the 9.99 kim was still herself when
she signed the divorce papers
was there an additional trauma final
straw
that sent her to florida must be
something big right um well no because
i mean at least
from at least story wise she was on her
way to florida either way
um you know she was she was going there
and you know she's not in hiding uh we
kind of talked about this
quite a lot in the last stream i did
with gil uh
you know she's not in hiding she's she's
she's just
this she's just making choices
she's just making the choice to not make
choices because of
the consequences of what what happened
before when she was doing that
and there's you know there's obviously
she she may be trying to punish herself
and and i think i don't think there
needs to be another
additional
final straw i think her situation with
she's in love with with jimmy but knows
that they can't be together and she she
sees in this in this uh last interaction
his self-imposed um
like what he's doing to himself
and i mean that's pretty bad uh i i
don't know do you think there's another
thing in there or i i think
i think it's set up the way that it is
i mean that's pretty much it i i do like
how the way that she talks to saul there
it's almost like you know she wants them
to say something she wants them to
reconcile at least a little bit not like
they're going to get back together but
at least have some sort of better ending
you know leave things off on a better
note but saul just doesn't allow that
um i think that is kind of the final
straw and like well i'm not gonna miss
anything here you know he has the chance
to talk to me or say something final and
he won't
uh but yeah she definitely was already
on her way to florida and i do think
that her situation with uh with howard
was was more than enough to uh give her
all the trauma that she could ever need
yeah
yeah she's living with that you know
every day
over that over that time period it's not
it's not hard for me to imagine that
that she you know
she
becomes the person that we saw in 612.
matthew whalen thank you for the 999 bob
odenkirk has the opportunity to deliver
an oscar level performance when his
water works eventually happens in the
finale right
yeah i mean the
we were i was talking to
i guess it was courtney after the uh
stream
that i mean
the
the stream with bob and ray yesterday
like yeah there's definitely um
there's a there's a big scene coming
the waterworks
i mean
when those two
do
if we see a conversation with jimmy
and
kim
not you know not miracle whip uh
brunette kim but you know the real
people again
um it is going to be a water works kind
of situation
yeah i mean it's definitely definitely
open to interpretation i i don't think
it's too far from the truth that we may
see saul just break down and cry himself
uh over what i'm not too sure um we have
seen him cry a handful of times
throughout the show usually it's uh
usually it's fake you know whether he's
crying to mess with chuck's insurance or
he's crying to stall the uh the mall cop
uh one of the only times i can think of
when he actually cries is during the
season four finale after that whole
christie esposito situation when he goes
back to his car
um yeah that's what i was thinking about
was that was the only one i could think
about
yeah so i mean it would be nice to see
well not that i want to see bob cry or
saul cry but
it'd be nice to have him you know at
least offload some emotions uh in a
maybe in a similar way to kim in 612 you
know kind of crying about everything she
had bottled up over the past six years
so it'd be nice to actually see some
emotion from uh gene in this final
episode with him uh finally
maybe
not compartmentalizing everything
anymore
yeah and it would be good to see yes
that crispy christie esposito one you
know he did that alone
out of you know out out of
nobody around to see it happen um
it would be good to see him
you know do that
so that not not because you know
for any other reason but just for kim to
to see that that that happened that it
took place you know what i mean
yeah because i think i think that that's
what she she she's hoping for like
there's not very very many good options
of what can happen with this guy right
now but
i think for her you know that would be
what what she's hoping that he he
doesn't stay
you know in that in that
torturous situation for the rest of his
life that he's put himself into
graft gold thank you for the five jimmy
sacrifices his life to protect kim from
any legal consequences
explain why kim lied to cheryl about him
being alive he may soon be dead um
jimmy sacrifices his life to protect him
from any legal consequence so is is
i've seen the theory that maybe that was
a flash forward and that
um
it happens out of it happens after
whatever happens to gene or something
like that i'm not sure if that's what
this is saying
um
i mean i i think it could be something
along the lines of
gene sacrifices himself so he purposely
dies so that he can't be a witness to
kim's confession so that she doesn't go
to jail but kim almost seems like she
wants to go to prison for it so i don't
really think that
she would see that as a sacrifice you
know i think she's okay whether or not
she goes to prison just whatever happens
happens is where she's at um
i don't know i i do think that uh
everything in 612 happens alongside each
other because i do think that
you know jimmy jimmy self-destructs in 6
11 6 12 after the phone call and kim tur
wants to turn herself in after the phone
call i think that everything is because
of that phone call the way that they
both snap and change the way that
they're acting
um
yeah i'm not i'm not too sure if kim
wants to uh
wants to stay out of jail or if she
would even really care much about that i
feel like she almost wants to go to
prison after everything to be honest
yeah i'm not sure if she wants to but i
i think she's she's okay with it if
that's what the way it goes you know
what i mean
she's she's she's willing to take the
consequences
um
yeah i don't know if i can add anything
else to that i mean
it's uh
they're
yeah okay there's i can't think of
anything better to add to that
granny gamer one thank you for the five
this is all ability
abeleta's fault
yeah and in a way if she wouldn't have
ran away after she hit the skateboarders
it's funny because you know people
uh you know we always look for those
those funny things like you know well if
this hadn't happened then nothing else
would happen and you could always go one
step further you know if you think if
you agree on one point then you can
always take a step back and go to
another one
so yeah it could all we could we could
put all of this down on uh
tuco's grandmother
yeah well i that's that's one thing that
i love about this show everything has a
huge domino effect right like if uh
if mike wouldn't of uh
you know messed with hector you know
robbed his truck then he wouldn't have
uh
messed with his supply
chain through gus and then hector
wouldn't have uh put his eyes on nacho's
father and then nacho wouldn't have uh
you know tried to kill hector and then
lala would have been introduced and then
he wouldn't have tried to get lalo
killed and then nacho wouldn't have died
so in a way nacho's dead because of mike
or also like you know if uh
you know nacho only introduced uh saul
the lalo because nacho knew because of
tuko and this that and the third thing
and you know everything from their most
recent seasons can always be related
back to to the beginning of the show
honestly and that's that's something
that i that i love doing with the show
just going down the rabbit hole and uh
you know
same with the back and forth with jimmy
and uh jimmy and chuck you know like oh
well if jimmy wouldn't have switched the
numbers but he only did that because
chuck was kind of extorting kim but she
she was only doing that because this
then a third i don't know uh you can
just go back and forth for forever with
so many differences
yeah big ralph thank you for the twenty
dollars kim did make a move to redeem
herself by coming forward if kim gets
charged with serious crime
gene jimmy can redeem himself somewhat
by being on the verge of getting away
and giving himself up or turning himself
in or something along those lines to
save kim
yeah i i don't have a lot to add to what
you're saying there big ralph it's very
uh succinct and to the point and it
makes sense um
that would be a lot more satisfying than
him being caught i guess you know that
that's the the big takeaway i have is
that um
i i i it's still a little bit of a
step down in that he's doing it to save
kim instead of
you know
for for for the you know for just for
the reason of just wanting to
you know not be what he's what he's
doing you know i mean like not really
but i mean there's a lot of different
ways that that can make sense too so i
don't know do you have anything else to
add to this one um chase
i mean you could see him doing it in
such a way because that's what kim
wanted him to do
so that could really have an effect on
him but again i'm not sure if he would
ever turn himself in willingly if he's
going to keep going down swinging but
and i'm not too sure if uh if him
if him turning himself in would really
make her happy or if she was just
projecting herself onto him to be honest
well i mean i think about like what the
what the characters are doing and and
how they go how old they
how will i think about them after the
fact you know um
if kim gets charged with a serious crime
you know ralph's saying here that he'll
be on the verge of getting away and and
yeah that would be good for jimmy if if
he if he had a chance to get away
and and he changed his mind and he did
the right thing
because that's what we want him to do
right we want him to do the right thing
but that that makes kim's
purpose kind of just to get him to do
the right thing
and kind of takes away i think a little
bit from her story or whatever they're
trying to tell about her you know what i
mean it it makes her makes her a lot
more of a side character that is
uh you know
in service of what he's doing so yeah i
mean
as long as he gets there and it makes
sense i'll be happy with it um
the details you know we'll see how they
play out because
as you just
as you were just uh pointing out with
the last thing you know there's so many
things there's we could just go on and
on about different directions it could
go and um yeah you know that in the in
the
at the end of the day we trust them and
until they do something to to to violate
that trust then
um
it's all just kind of us uh doing mental
gymnastics
carl borchers thank you for the 9.99 a
co-worker was a big deal but uh a
co-worker was a big drug dealer in the
past he had
millions thousands of acres in wyoming
yachts etc
he ended up on the run for years
turned himself in because he couldn't
take the isolation
yeah i mean that's difficult um
i think there's a point where it it you
know if if you you can get away
but if you don't have any kind if you if
there's nothing left if you have nothing
but the running
then i think there's a natural point
where you get to where you have to say
that this is not worth it this is you
know
uh i want this to end
um
i hope that's not how this this show
goes though because that would be
i mean it could it could happen there
could be time jumps and things like that
but um
i'd like to see it i'd like to see it a
little bit tighter and you know
let it all play out in
in a relative amount of time
i mean that that definitely can relate
to gene right because jimmy and saul
were always such charismatic social
people or a social person
and uh
and isolation makes anyone go crazy but
him especially because he was always
just so
is so you know the the the life of the
party is so to speak so
i mean
his core drive is that he wants people
to like him he wants to be loved i mean
that's what the creators have said um
in isolation you get none of that nobody
nobody responds to anything that you do
or
anything you know i mean that was sort
of the whole thing with uh new hampshire
for walt right he he was alive he got
away he had his barrel of money but he
was uh
couldn't even go outside
that's no way to live uh mj mj323 thank
you for the five dollars if saul knew
where howard is buried it opens up
interesting options i also wonder if
kim's hair change is a wig and maybe she
is actually
sick terminal
um
yeah i don't think he does know where
howard's buried i can't see any reason
why
i can't think of anything that any way
that would come out where it wouldn't
seem completely contrived um
mike should mike should never have
really needed to tell him that
and um
it would have to be a pretty
kind of
crazy situation if they tried to you
know shoehorn that in to say like oh
yeah well they were having this
conversation and it just came up
it doesn't seem right
i also wonder if kim's hair change is a
wig and maybe she is actually sick
terminal i hadn't um i hadn't thought
about that
i'm not sure how that would improve the
story
but it could be it could be the case i
mean it definitely is a wig but um
i don't think i don't think it's
supposed to be
yeah it's kind of
kind of kind of a little bit obvious
though i mean oh my goodness like
i i don't know i i think that that
hairstyle is just atrocious on her i
think that's kind of the point with the
whole contrast between the way that
we're used to seeing her i'm all for
people you know trying out a new style
and not to say that that hairdo is is
bad you know i've seen other people rock
that kind of style but i just it just
does not suit her it's just just wow
when that first reveal with the miracle
whip scene when i saw that my jaw was
like what
like okay sure i don't know it baffled
me it baffled me
yeah it's funny because i saw a lot of
people pointing out how
you know the potato kind of the cutting
the potato and how that was a mirror of
um
jeans uh
you know his first um
his introduction at cinnabon and and
yeah
it's funny how that hits so much there
like it feels it feels like a a much uh
bigger jump
in the in the case of kim because we've
seen
like like jimmy is already the second
version of saul that we saw you know
like chronologically watching it
so seeing him as someone different
it's not as it's not as crazy although
it absolutely was the first time i
uh you know watched season one i was
like what the heck is going on here like
why is this in black and white who is
this mustachioed person
uh where does this fit in with
everything anything you know it was it
was completely mysterious
ruari gar
gogherty thank you for the 10 pound
episodes 10 through 12 have made jimmy
seem a lot less likable as gene in saul
and breaking bad era
intentional so we don't feel sympathy if
he goes to jail
as jimmy i was rooting for him and never
viewed him as a bad guy
no i mean i don't think that's why it
could be but i don't think that's why i
think it's more of
they know that we that we do feel that
way about jimmy so it's hard for us to
watch him
go down this path and then you know
obviously we'll hope that he can he can
turn it around
um i mean i think they're pretty good at
gauging
our expectations and what we want to see
and what what what we might be thinking
uh when we watch particular
things play out and i think yeah this is
this is more about setting up a will he
won't he
kind of come back around situation
i mean i i do really think that they
have done a great job sort of treading
that line because
they do things where we're like oh oh
wow he actually is kind of a bad person
but they don't take it too far to the
point that he's not irredeemable right
like if he would have actually killed
marion then that would have been to the
point that it's like okay who even
really cares what happens to him anymore
because he's just a horrible person he
killed this old lady or if he would have
actually you know killed that guy with
cancer it's bad enough that he that he
robbed him um
but i just think that that's just sort
of treading the line of okay well
you know maybe i'm losing a little bit
of sympathy for him because of the
horrible things that he's done but at
the same time he still is a tragic
character he still does have that
sympathy he hasn't quite become totally
irredeemable uh
and and the same thing could be said for
for kim because after the whole howard
situation i just genuinely didn't like
her as a person anymore um but then
she kind of takes off her blinders and
realizes the consequences to her actions
and uh
and feels bad for it at the end of 609
so i think that was at least a little
bit redeemable and the fact that she's
so shaken up over it bottling it up for
all these six years um it really does
make you sympathize with her and what
she's going through
so i think they do a really good job
treading the line where they almost make
you hate these characters but at the
same time they don't take it too far to
the point that yeah they're they're
irredeemable
yeah i think that's the point um jeremy
thank you for the 199 jace final scam
get k exonerated and take the fall
yeah i mean this is what i was talking
about a few minutes ago i i don't really
want to see
um
you know i i i don't want i don't really
want to see that to be the the whole
purpose of the character of of uh
kim wexler is
you know to be like the whole the whole
line
back in season two you know you don't
save me i save me i mean that's that's
who the character is so having jimmy
save her at the end or
you know make the sacrifice for her in
some way doesn't really seem fitting to
me
yeah she doesn't she doesn't really need
saving so to speak but i mean you could
always appreciate the sentiment but i
see what you mean by you want her to
sort of have her own ending and her own
uh
you know original uh conclusion instead
of just being a supporting character to
jimmy because she really has broken out
as as her own main character over the
past few seasons
yeah absolutely
slant matt
thank you for the
13.99 canadian do you have any thoughts
on what will finally transition gene
jimmy's world back to color
it seems inevitable
but how do you envision it happening
yeah i don't know i mean
it seems like it should have happened or
it could have happened and
and and there's a lot there's so much
riding on it now that it it almost like
has to be
uh
really subtle
or they they have to lean into it in a
way that makes it almost like uh
a dream sequence or something like that
you know i mean like where like if it's
because he sees
kim again or if he you know or if he has
that you know if he has that aha moment
where where he
you know where the wall breaks down and
he's able to to
you know experience what what we wanted
him to experience or whatever like
it's gonna it
they're gonna have to they're gonna have
to handle it in a way that it it's like
um
it seems seamless you know like that's
not distracting in a way right
because it can be really kind of corny
like if it if it's if it's a big
distracting thing i mean i i think back
to you know like
uh the wizard of oz like the the reason
why that
changed from black and white to color is
so
so
incredible is because of the way that
they set it up i mean it but that's
that's literally like a dream you know
how can they do that in in a grounded um
you know character drama
i'm not sure
i mean i i definitely was was waiting to
say that i i like how you bring up how
it's corny because even though it is
kind of corny i do like the idea of the
gene kim reunion you know being the
classic cliche theory of uh what brings
his life to color there could be many
other things that that do it right like
does he
does he die somehow does that bring it
to color does he go to jail and maybe
you know you know accepting or even if
he doesn't go to prison just sort of
being able to let go of his past and
move on with his life in whatever
fashion that is because he's never been
able to let go of his past i mean he
compartmentalizes it but he still holds
all those mementos even as saul he holds
all the mementos from his life as jimmy
and then as genie has that shoe box full
of his past um i think that maybe one
day
you know he might be able to actually
move on with his life and let everything
go um
that's the thing right i think that it
is a corny idea that being said i i do
love it um i mean who knows maybe it
won't go into color and the only bit of
color we ever do see is the reflection
of his commercials and his glasses i
still think that's a great full circle
moment uh yeah i trust the creators and
we'll just have to wait and see what
happens but even if it is a little bit
corny i think i'm still gonna like it um
but if they don't do it i i won't be
disappointed
yeah um
i'm super curious like
it'd be weird if it doesn't happen but
it's like one of those things that's
sort of like the breakup or or you know
when kim's gonna leave his life you know
whenever you're going into that episode
uh 609 you think i don't like any of the
options that's kind of where i'm at
right now and and that worked out
splendidly so i'm i'm assuming that this
will as well
ramsey bolton thank you for the five
euro when saul says to kim have a nice
life it's clear he acts because before
that you see he is nervous about it
he just wants to look cool to her um
yeah we we touched on this earlier
hopefully you were here when we when we
brought that up um
i mean
francesca says on the thing that it's
been an hour
so he it took him an hour to to
get himself prepared and bouncing the
ball around
before he lets her in so
it's absolutely what they were going for
there um
it's not easy for him
francesca
francesco
ciara thank you for the five euro are
you sure mr white died on breaking bad's
ending because i see
bcs finishing just after
breaking bad
yeah this is all pretty settled um
he died in september the phone call
between jimmy and kim is in
november
um they definitely like that i mean it
wasn't really a uh
it wasn't really supposed to be
ambiguous of whether walt died or not um
but fans obviously kind of talked about
that a little bit after the finale
and they they said that
specifically in el camino for that
reason right isn't there like a yeah
yeah they they mention it it's either on
the
on the tv with suzanne erickson or it's
uh over the radio when i think it might
be over the radio in the car when
jesse's listening to it
um
i i don't know i
i
i don't know because like back in the
day i don't know if it was one of the
first videos he'd ever ever did on that
channel but film theory did a video
about walt surviving and i mean when i
very first saw that video when it first
came out it kind of almost sold me on
the idea um
but again it would have uh kind of
weakened the impact of the finale and i
i do accept that walt's dead um they did
mention an el camino i'm not sure if
during the franchesca call uh did gene
taught when gene was talking to
francesca yeah
about the maestro or whatever was that
yeah but
in the farm yeah yeah
yeah so i mean they've they've confirmed
it a few times here um
yeah
yeah and like i said the timeline's
pretty solid we're we're past that um
so yeah you're getting ready to take off
uh chase uh so i'll give you a chance to
say goodbye and um
plug your channel before you go
yeah for sure thanks for having me on i
really appreciate it it's always a lot
of fun coming on stream
i really enjoyed being able to uh to
discuss any and all theories uh for the
finale of the show it's a it's really
it's surreal that uh that this is coming
to an end uh even though that may be the
case you know i'm sure there's still
going to be lots to talk about after the
finale ends and i still have a lot of uh
ideas for uh better call saul and
breaking bad content planned for the
future you know we can always go back
and do retrospectives and analysis and
this that a third thing tearless
icebergs yadda yadda just the fact that
the whole prediction theory
aspect of it is uh pretty much gonna be
over i mean i guess we can always do
theories of what happens
afterwards depending on how
uh how ambiguous the ending is
uh but yeah uh i hope you guys enjoy the
rest of peach stream thanks for having
me on it was a lot of fun once you're
done with the stream if you want more
better call salt content feel free to
check out my channel i believe the link
is in the description i just uploaded my
612 review recently and i did a kim and
jesse video
i also got that season four tier list
and five and six and all that i'm
working on uh just uh sort of chipping
away at it here and there uh but yeah i
got some other obligations i need to go
go take care of uh so it's about time i
hit the old dusty trail i hope you have
a great rest of your stream and i'm sure
we'll be uh talking lots about the
finale when uh when that does come to
fruition so yeah thanks again i
appreciate it
all right man we'll talk soon um have a
good one
cheers
yeah
all right uh i will
get through all these i'll stay as long
as i need to to answer all your
questions um francesco again thank you
for the 2.02 euro
bcs ending
like
shakespeare's romeo and juliet
[Music]
yeah
i don't know about that
uh we'll see um
we'll see
i don't know how we get to that point
but um
if anything comes to my mind as i'm
answering these other questions i'll
come back to that uh man
manu john thank you for the
40
um
it's all going to vacuum guy which means
salgon
yeah i like i said i don't think this
would be a satisfying ending for him to
just disappear there's also the idea
that you know maybe he tries that and it
doesn't work out because he's dead or
something like that but um
again i wouldn't like to see it that's
not the way i would get there if i was
if i was writing the story but i'm not a
writer so you know like maybe they'll
maybe they'll surprise us in that way
but i yeah i i think saul gone that what
i hope is is that that personality is
gone and gone forever and
that's what i want to see i want to you
know i want to see
him kill that part of himself and uh you
know see what's left of jimmy and
you know what where he can go from there
big ralph thank you for the 20 again
that's very generous cheryl is still
wearing her wedding ring in episode 12.
you go back to episode six she treated
howard like
you know not well i feel bad for cheryl
but her own behavior puts a limit on how
much sympathy i can have for her anybody
else
i've seen this a little bit in the
comments but what i don't understand is
they never made it clear why they
weren't getting along
you know like
i don't really i can't really have a
feeling about uh
cheryl because
uh howard
you know he was he was mostly a good guy
and
you know he he did
commendably deal with his trauma after
what happened with with chuck but i mean
it's not it's not
it's not unthinkable to me that he may
have been
you know he may have been deserving of
what he was having
in that conversation with her like he
you know he just because he's
he's good at his job or whatever doesn't
mean that he was a good husband
and um you know they had their issues he
mentions that he brings it up at the
therapist so
um
yeah she she dumped out the latte that
he put together but we don't know what
he did to get them to to get her to that
point of of being like that you know
what i mean um
so yeah i i don't know and she is
wearing the
uh you know i don't know that she's
wearing the ring she's wearing an
engagement ring in that shot i'm not
sure if that's supposed to
uh i i think that's supposed to be his
but um we don't really know you know it
could be like it could be a hint that
she's she's finally moving on years
later uh i didn't hear them make any
clarifications about that in interviews
or anything that came out after
so i'll have to say that i'm not exactly
sure
um i have seen to answer your question
though
specifically when you say anybody else
i've seen a lot of people bring that up
in the comments but
i just can't really follow it because
like i said we don't know what what made
cheryl the person that she was in that
conversation
kmj 2318 thank you for the five dollars
in my opinion the final scene is a
flashback we need to decipher the
flashback to determine what happens
whether gene turns himself in for
example
so you say in my opinion which is kind
of throwing me off a little bit i think
what you're saying is you're guessing
that the final scene in the series that
we haven't seen yet will be a flashback
and then we have to decipher
to determine what happens
that's an interesting idea that would be
something that could be different
and fun
but i don't know what else to say about
it than that because we haven't seen it
yet
otherwise i'm misinterpreting your
question and i'm sorry about that but
i i
i think that's that's what i'm getting
from it uh the way you wrote it
let's see scrolling scrolling scrolling
uh here's one josh
shermer thank you for the 4.99
kim lures saul to meet and sets him up
to be arrested that would be i would be
really surprised with that i don't know
why she would have to do that i think
she asked him to turn himself in
i feel like that's where she drew the
line
later whenever she sees cheryl she
doesn't say that she knows he's around
and she doesn't turn him in herself so
i would be really shocked if that
happens
and they would have to do a pretty good
job
in the way they delivered it for me to
actually be okay with it
but it's possible
pd thank you for the five any chance
that jimmy's redemption is taking
responsibility
for all he and kim's nonsense
yeah i mean
if he did something similar to what kim
just did
that would certainly count as taking
responsibility as far as i'm concerned
um
he's in the he's pretty far from that
where he's at right now
so yeah that's what we're looking for in
the finale is to is to close that gap
but but yeah i mean i think
i think reckoning with what he's done
is a path to redemption for this
character
he can't make it right obviously um but
that's the kind of thing that we want to
see at least that's what i want to see
matt rozelle thank you for the five is
it possible they've foreshadowed jimmy
taking his own life chuck hanging
himself in claw chuck
who killed himself hanging self in
closet line
wanting to go to belize
well if he did kill himself you could go
back and look at all those things
and and say that they they support that
i don't think it was foreshadowing when
they did those things if that's what
even how it turns out i mean they didn't
know
whenever they made those scenes and
especially like the hanging yourself in
the closet line they had no idea that
there was even going to be
they're going to be in the situation to
have to write this character's ending so
if they did if it was for if it felt
like foreshadowing it'd be that idea
that where they go back and mine things
that that have already happened to you
know inform what happens now
not the other way around it definitely
wasn't something that they knew
ahead of time
randy soyamatsu thank you for the 499 is
the breaking or is the black and white
timeline confirmed to be now
could there be more and more time jump
even one scene or epilogue
like kim taking the oath again jimmy
parole there could be the the black and
white timeline is confirmed to be in
2010.
this phone call that's on the screen
right now that's november 12
2010 jimmy's birthday
and also the receptionist at uh
palm springs palm coast sprinklers they
share the same birthday because we saw
the kim have to go sing happy birthday
to her
right afterwards um
there could definitely be another
flash forward it just depends on how
things play out
uh i've seen a ton of theories about
like what might happen after he gets out
of prison theories and some of them are
not not too bad they're not not where i
would go in the first place but um i
like those a lot better than the
jimmy just being
super cool in prison and uh you know
living it up being a shady lawyer for
for criminals in that situation
so we'll see al bundy thank you for the
two dollars thoughts on kim back in
albuquerque being a flash forward i
touched on this earlier
and um i saw that and those are the
kinds of theories that you read it and
you're like oh yeah maybe maybe uh
and then when you think about it a
little bit longer i don't think it holds
up um
you know i i think
chase said it earlier i think that the
uh you know the the event
that puts that in motion is her talking
to to jimmy they're talking to gene and
him saying why don't you turn yourself
in you know
at that point
he he says you know that that that fring
is in the ground mike is in the ground
lalo is apparently in the ground so
there's nothing that's really stopping
her from going back and i think she just
realizes that in that in that moment but
you know it like i said it's one of
those theories you're eating you said oh
what if what if
that's after i don't i don't think it
holds up but i guess we'll see
uchida
ogoname thank you for the five i think
howard's wife deserves to be the one who
gets the spill to the feds despite his
charm
he's a sociopath who needs to pay what
do you think well i don't think he's a
sociopath um
you know
i just
that's something that we've seen him do
the right thing
um especially early on when he was
trying to impress
his brother
so i i don't think so i i think he's
i think he's pretty far from his best
self
in in the saul goodman timeline and in
obviously in the gene and
towards especially the end of where
we're at right now um but
i you know
we'll see it depends on his decisions
going forward still i guess the the
jury's still out but for me
not a not a sociopath
but
not not
he does need to i mean not that he
should avoid concert or you know like he
shouldn't get away with any of what he
did either i'm not saying that you know
it's
i'm fine with him um
facing this consequences but
you know
i still i still find him sympathetic
jb 315 thank you for the 10 could easily
imagine gene getting safely back to his
apartment
grabbing the shoebox and turning around
to see a silent dog sitting there
followed by buddy nabbing him well i
would like to see the dog return i think
that would be a great
little surprise there
otherwise though i don't really see why
buddy
would be getting involved
so yeah i'm trying to put it together in
a way that it makes sense
i feel like
you know
i see a lot of people talking about um
about jeff being stuck in in jail and i
i don't think that'll turn out to be
very consequential um any of that
it's more about what his decisions are
going forward
but we'll see
richard seymour thank you for the 10
maybe he takes chuck's advice in the end
you're gonna hurt everyone around you
you can't help it so stop apologizing
and accept it embrace it frankly i'd
have more respect for you if you did
that's one of the one that's one of the
main reasons why i don't want to see an
ending where he gets away with it i
don't want chuck to be right in that um
obviously chuck was right about some
things he was also a complete ass
and uh you know
treated his brother terribly
so yeah that would be that would be an
unsatisfying ending of the series if it
was all about chuck being right and uh
jimmy leaning in and going with that
for me you know
amy thought amy fox thanks you for the
20 australian do you think jean saul
will finally feel remer remorse and turn
back to jimmy
do you think he will sacrifice himself
so kim does not go to prison um
kind of touched on all these things
and this is kind of what i talked about
in my in my last video if you haven't
seen it yet the uh
the please kill saul goodman
video that it was about that and yes i i
do
hope
that he'll finally feel re remorse and
turn back to jimmy i hope that that i
mean i feel like that that um
the teaser which we haven't really
talked about here
i feel like his esteem you know that
that's sort of what that is that's a
piece of him
it's a piece of jimmy that still exists
out there in the world and it's all
battered and
and kind of
pushed to the side and out of view but
it's still there you know and that's
what i'm hoping and that we'll get to
see that and um the sacrifice part you
know we kind of talked about this a
couple of times
it's fine if that happens in the process
of him
him
realizing that and and you know and and
and doing that i hope i hope he doesn't
only
do that so that kim does not go to
prison uh because that's sort of
in contrast to her you don't save me i
saved me and
i don't think she would actually
appreciate that in that way and he
should know that
because they've been together for a long
time now so
that's where i would land on all that
barbara sebill thank you for the ten
dollars thanks for the great coverage
and insight huge fan of you kiwi and
courtney
uh yeah thanks for that barbara and um i
saw some other people mention courtney
in the the comments
uh she she wasn't able to make either
one this week because
she was busy but um i think that
you'll be seeing her one more time
before the season's over and um
yeah
uh i really appreciate this um
and i'm gonna be really sad whenever
this is over because i can't i won't be
able to so easily do it anymore it's
been a lot of fun
it's funny because streaming is not like
it's definitely not something that uh
i went into
it's not my personality to sit here and
and think that uh people want to hear me
talk about
my thoughts for
two or three hours in a row
so uh it's been it's been fun in a way
that i hadn't expected
thank you for the 9.99 i feel like
howard's body will be found with the
connection to mike being known
it's possible i think it's a pretty big
stretch
and i'm not sure what it would add to
the story other than
there's there is evidence
um so yeah like i said i think it's
possible
but i i personally i don't need to see
it happen um
you know it did say if you look it is uh
it is
their names are in there gus spring mike
ehrman trout all of it she laid it out
as it happened
so yeah there is a thing and
uh she even said that to to uh cheryl
she said they will search
but you know
we'll see if they get there or not that
that'll
like it wouldn't ruin it for me i just
think that um
it wouldn't be i don't i don't i don't
need i don't need howard's body for for
closure personally
big ralph thank you for the two kiwi
pete courtney and one take rule thanks
yeah thanks again um
yeah and gil will definitely be back on
tuesday
he doesn't like to do the preview ones
because he doesn't like to watch the
teasers and things like that so um
he's always out on saturday but
we'll be doing it again on tuesday for
sure
erin olds thank you for the five did
anyone else see the creepy silhouette at
the end of the theme
does that mean anything in particular
uh yeah that was kim
um i have it right here somewhere
that was just a shot of kim returning to
albuquerque and it was this uh like one
of those little uh
things that happened later in the
episode that they showed and you wonder
what it is until you see it
and we did see that when she walked out
and that was an act you know the exact
same shot of uh
that we saw whenever um
uh jesse picks up walled outside the
same airport
in the uh van before four days out or
whatever one that they want to to cook
in breaking bad
really cool thank you for the 10. at the
courthouse kim sees ponytails stiletto
heeled lawyer coaching pd client
panned to black and white kim in
sensible shoes
another kim flashback or kim u-turn
after bus scene back to albuquerque in
the finale
uh i don't think so
gil brought this opportunity brought
this up in the in the last trailer that
maybe she she's definitely at the
airport and she's getting ready to leave
but maybe there's an intervention um
it's possible i don't think he was like
uh i don't want to
misrepresent i don't think he was saying
it as something that he thought would
happen like he just said that it you
know it's a possibility because we don't
see her get on a plane
or or return to florida like physically
but um
i think you know the the crying scene is
is the beginning of the turn you know
like she did what she had to do
i mean she's there in the first place
for that reason right she made a
decision
she followed through with it she's
feeling
part of what she's repressed in that
moment
and
and feelings
feeling bad about
feeling remorse for for what happened as
a result of
of that scam so
i think she is in in the process of
changing
um she's not going to be the same same
uh you know person that she was
in the beginning of that episode
but i don't know where it goes from here
i i do believe that there'll be
there'll be one more crossing a paths if
not like face to face then at least on
the telephone between her and and gene
but um
it's kind of hard to figure out how we
get there if it doesn't involve
him going to court
and even then it's still kind of um
you know it's still kind of hard
bobby burak thank you for the two does
gold have final say on ending or him
slash vince well i mean vince is a
producer
but gould is the showrunner
and gould they're co-creators but i mean
i think they have i mean obviously they
they have
they're they're they work together
professionally for a long time so
there's a mutual respect and and i'm
sure there's a natural back and forth
but
technically the showrunner has final say
on everything that's what a showrunner's
job is um
they they have to sign off on the
scripts from the the writer's room i
mean gould's obviously involved in the
writer's room and all of those different
aspects but i mean that's what the
showrunner does is they have the final
creative con you know say on on
what gets in and what doesn't they can
veto anything they can they have to go
and they have to fight with the
producers sometimes for money when they
need it for certain things to make sure
stuff happens
there's a lot there's a lot but yeah i
mean if if just talking technically
gold has the final say
ricky dental thank you for the five
dollars canadian best show ever but one
thing i was expecting slash hoping for
was more of gus's back backstory in
santiago santiago any theories on gus
and peter and maybe max there um
not really uh i mean as far as theories
i i think that you know
the implication is that he was somebody
important enough that the cartel
won't kill him
uh i mean i know what happened in in
chile with uh pinochet uh
and all of that i'm not sure i mean i i
you know i just always assumed that he
was a war criminal of sorts and um
you know the you know they did gus or uh
peter gould and vince did say on the
inside the gill verse that that we won't
find out
it's not gonna happen
they did spoil that that there will
there will be no insight into it in the
finale um
and i think it's i'm just okay with that
you know like i know that i know that
max was his
his partner and that's his motivation i
thought they did a really great
uh you know final scene with him there
just to sort of drive that home
is that you know and that does put a
little different twist on on who he is
when we see him in breaking bad but
um
beyond that i think it's just it's just
uh
details that you know they could be
interesting
but
they could also kind of ruin the
mystique so
what you know why not why not just uh
let it be the mystery and let us think
about it
dancing sean thank you for the 10 we
know they use color with purpose yellow
equals uncertainty transition green
equals cover protection
red criminality pink seems to be crime
adjacent jason how do you think orange
is distinguished from red um
pink seems to be crime adjacent how do
you think orange is distinguished from
red uh i mean if you're going just from
that it it should be it should be
similar um
and i'm trying to i'm trying to piece
this together with what what you're
getting at because it's i know you asked
this question a long time ago
um
about 44 minutes ago and i don't know
what i was talking about 44 minutes ago
i wish i had something better to say
here um
i mean orange is the combination of
yellow and red
so if if you're talking about
you know if they're if they if they're
thinking literally like that
then uh uncertain criminality is where
you get to um
from a color theory point of view
but yeah i'm not sure
not sure what else to say about that
sorry dancing sean uh sucked 199 i feel
final scene will be a
flashback to a happier time
could be we mentioned this earlier
they're jumping all around in the
timeline so there's really nothing that
keeps them
tethered to a linear
linear uh
situation but i do hope that they
i do hope that they uh
you know
don't over explain things
so you know a flashback might be uh a
fitting end in that situation you know
kmj 2318 thank you for the five you
don't say me i saved me still rings in
my head gene might think he's helping
kim only to screw things up that's been
a theme yeah and i hope that he i hope
that he also understands this um
you know we were talking about that
earlier about how the idea of
the break the broken trust that marian
is talking about that he she trusted him
how that might tie back to the lalo
thing with kim
and that's what she was trying to avoid
right she knew jimmy would try to
protect her and he would try to uh make
things all right
and that's why she didn't do it that's
part of the reason why she didn't do it
so
yeah i would like to i'd like to hope
that he doesn't make that same mistake
but you know we can't say for sure
he does have to something has to to move
him in the direction but we don't know
what it's going to be
i would like for him to to make the
choice
i think that kim would like to see him
make the choice i think it would mean
more
so yeah i'm right there with you
arie ozone thank you for the 4.99 could
there be an epilogue that takes place in
the actual present day
jimmy and kim would be elderly or is
that too corny um
i mean it sounds corny
but
that doesn't necessarily mean it would
be because you know i mean like they
could probably pull it off
would they be elderly in 2022
uh
it's only 10 years
12 years to be exact
i don't i don't know it would be the f
for them to be elderly and for it to be
like really kind of uh
set apart from where they're at right
now it would have to be in the far
future
and i don't know i guess the more i
think about
you know
the more thing about things like that
the cornier it sounds but i don't know
these guys can can do anything if they
put their mind to it so you know
i'll we'll see
uh there's a ton just just to answer
your you know could that be or could be
i mean there's a ton of theories out
there that of of stuff that happens
after
like you know
saul goes to prison or you know does his
time and gets out or you know there's
that a lot of people are thinking about
that and if it's possible so
it's you know it's not it's not
you're not alone in those and those and
wondering those things uh connor mahoney
thank you for the 199 euro gene plays a
on
piano and music suggests a major
um
you know i i i don't know what to say um
i saw him hit a key on the piano and
that's as far as my mind went i was like
why is he doing that the guy he's
testing if the guy is going to wake up
or not it seems like he could have done
that a different way
i i don't know how to i don't i don't
know the difference between a and a
major so i can't really say there
pinworm thank you for the five what's
the possibility that the last episode
ends in 2022 think of the possibilities
i just answered this uh with the last
question so
and agree there are a lot of
possibilities that they did that
i'm not sure what else i can add to it
ron martin thank you for the five what
spin-off shows have you heard of that
might be coming out of bb and bcs
well i mean it's pretty aw
i mean they've been pretty honest that
they're not thinking of anything in the
near future
um
gus's backstory is something that people
were just asking about there there's
been talk of that of maybe going back um
filling in the blanks there
filling in the banks on kim's background
was was a popular idea but i think that
that kind of loses its
uh
you know as we get to the end of her her
regular story that kind of loses its
appeal
um
i mean there's so many uh side
characters that they could do that would
probably be better than than one of the
main characters and and
um
i mean i think gus is the one thing
because his his story would be exciting
it'd be like inherently exciting um
but
i haven't heard any that i think are
great
there's tons of potential there if they
really wanted to do it though so
we'll see what happens
larry seltzer thank you for the 10 i'll
miss you too when it's over
yeah like i said
i'll miss all of you guys um i'll still
be making videos
but you know there has to be i guess
where we're all watching the same thing
at the same time i mean i've been uh for
the last since episode since season five
of better call saul i've been
i've been essentially doing this
full-time
um
and i'm gonna continue to do that uh so
hopefully
hopefully our our paths will cross again
when the next show that we're both
watching at the same time happens
um i can i pretty consistently throw
myself into whatever it is that i'm
doing so if you liked my better call saw
videos you'll probably like uh the other
ones
based on whatever it is that's on and
i'm covering
rambo ringo
499 thank you 4.99 euro i it can't be
it can't be a part of me so now it's a
part of you
i'm not sure what that comes from that's
not ringing a bell jay can't process his
feelings so goes saul goodman scamming
distracting the pain while inflicting it
on others that's absolutely true
um
that's that's what what that's what he's
doing
in the gene timeline now we're kind of
seeing where
it's not working and he's having to up
the ante and um
we're about to see how that
what that leads to
in the finale
let's see here uh
dual
dual
dual deer thank you for the five do you
think kim is the only thing that can get
gene to realize who he's become
stop being gene and return to jimmy
and scene's going back to color
well
i mean kim hasn't worked
yet
um
if you think about the two interactions
that they showed with her in in 612 you
know it didn't it didn't bring him back
he almost got there on the phone
and he was he was miles away
actively making sure that jimmy didn't
come out
in the divorce paper scene so yeah
i mean
she's not the only thing
um
but that but she's the only thing that
he really kind of cares about you know
what i mean like
you could tell in in 612 that
if there's anything that's keeping him
going like in his own twisted way like
it doesn't really make sense because
he's not doing it for her but like if
there's something that keeps him going
is it's the thought that
they might get back together and i think
that's where there gets really
interesting you know like um
he he actively pushed it away because it
hurts
but but yeah that it's definitely
something that's very real to him and
and has a has
you know it has
it plays a part in all of his decisions
whether he likes to admit it or not
brian serway thank you for the 10 if
jimmy is to achieve emotional catharsis
and self-actualization i i.e killing his
soul goodman persona and facing his
ghosts
what do you think that scene could look
like
yeah and i i s somebody else asked me
almost
the wording was a little different but
someone asked a very similar version of
this question
in my uh
on my last video and um
i saw it this morning whenever i was
getting ready and
i'm not really sure
um
what i what i what i what i thought
about that when i read it the last time
is like
i i i i'm so happy that it's in the
hands of bob odenkirk you know like we
talk a lot about
everybody
you know there's so many great actors in
this series and
um
when we saw when we saw kim seen in the
last episode uh you know that that's one
of the things that i've been thinking
about is that
that bob has one of those in him for
this character if they set it up that
way
and i'm not exactly sure but i i i can't
wait to see how he delivers that you
know that that's going to be
um
that's going to be one for the ages
dt thank you for the ten dollars
canadian i'd like to think jimmy
represent himself in court and being
presented with all he's done finally
break down and have to confront his
crimes
yeah yeah i mean this is sort of going
to what the the last person mentioned
too like is it what could that be
there's all these different kind of
situations where he could finally do
that
um
almost too many to do i mean if you like
this idea then
that's cool i mean there's nothing i
don't have anything to say to take away
from that um
like i said several times in the stream
i'd like to see him make that decision
on his own
but
he's also an addict you know he's also
an addict in active relapse uh so that's
not necessarily something that happens
it's complicated you know so
i don't wanna i don't wanna i don't want
my own
thing that i want to to to cut me off
from all these other things but
it kind of does because that's kind of
how our brains works
or you know work
amber t thank you for the 420. i
appreciate you so much pete it's been
great i appreciate you too i remember
you were uh
one of the first super chats that we had
gil and i had in our first stream
so yeah uh
thanks
thanks for the kind words and thanks for
showing up
kmj 2318 thank you for the 10
clarified predicting it being unknown if
gene turns himself in and the episode
ends with flashbacks one with chuck one
with walt and one with kim
and we debate what gene actually does
based on the combos now that would be
taking a uh
this is a follow-up to your last one i
remember reading in this uh you're
you're the wheels are turning inside
your head aren't they kmj 2318 as it's
it's a developing situation
yeah you know i like it
i'm caught up in it i i i like where
you're where you think i like what
you're thinking about and where you're
going i'm not sure how how well it holds
up
um
this would kind of take the um sopranos
ambiguity
ambiguity to a different level
that would be something we haven't seen
before
and and they could be i mean they could
be confident enough to try to do
something like that
i mean i don't think many shows could
get away with with with being like
that
uh you know
it seems
it seems a little
it's i don't know it seems a little
concept the
for you know it means like to get past
everyone that has to have
all the producers and everything else
but you know who knows uh it sounds it
sounds like a cool idea like you're
definitely
making me uh
i'm definitely thinking about it now
that you brought it up
and and you're on record if it does turn
out to be that way you're on record
right there everybody's seen it
so we'll see what happens
tf cooks
uh what about the ketamines and the lady
liberty
i feel like at this point
i don't need to know
i know it was theirs i know he has it
i'm okay with that
there was the idea that they could be
the people behind the scenes where you
know like that he was
he pulled them back in with the money
laundering and stuff like that
craig would be good with it but i mean i
feel like now we're kind of beyond the
point where that might come back up i
could be wrong though i mean we're going
to see walt again
we're going to go into that timeline
not all the way back to bcs necessarily
but that's even possible at this point
so yeah i don't know i i don't i think
that
if they could fit it in
i'm okay with them
explaining that but i i hope they don't
shoehorn it in just for that answer
because it's not really
necessary um
not re it's not relevant i guess for
what's happening right now at the moment
there's some big things going down and
uh that's a detail i can overlook in the
in the midst of that
um
let's see jb 315 thank you for the 10
thanks for excellent content pete
appropriate ending gene learns nothing
about himself
morality or the human experiences
doubles down on ego and successfully
runs for president of the united states
yeah
um
you know it's funny
because
we look at him through this moral lens
you know and
a lot of the things that he does and
this is sort of you know they pointed
this out throughout you know like um
i think you know one of the one of the
obvious ones was how chuck uses some of
the same things and and his pursuit of
justice you know and it's okay because
it's only jimmy so it's okay if he bends
the rules in order to catch him because
that's so important you know it's i i i
like the little joke here about the the
president of the united states is what
i'm trying to say in a roundabout way
not this particular president or the
last one but just the idea of power and
the things people do to get it and once
they get it the things they do to hold
on to it and um
you know the way we kind of look at that
as just
normal
shane parole thank you for the five
there is a writing team known for liking
to pay this is the writing team known
for liking to pay things off
yeah they're they're thorough they
definitely are uh you know one of the
things they do
i got to ask vince and peter a question
a couple weeks ago
in a super chat
and that was one that's what i asked
them was you know what is uh
not knowing where these characters were
going how did they how did they craft
those scenes earlier
in the series so that they can
because they always they definitely go
back to them like if you go back and
watch
the early scenes of their of kim and
jimmy's relationship they didn't know
kim was important they didn't know that
they were going to be together they
didn't know that the whole ending of the
series would hinge on what's going on
with them
uh you know but but yet
when you look back they they they did
before they wrote these they looked back
and they found all these different
things they could they could uh mine you
know or threads they could pull on
to make that all feel organic and all
make sense and um
yeah so i think what they do more than
like to pay things off is i think they
like to follow the characters
and you know let the characters lead
them and then you know they're they're
smart enough to go back
and uh you know connect things connect
the dots to make it feel satisfying you
know they they don't just um
they they they
they refer back to to things that that
that they know that we picked up on
and it's a really smart way to do it you
know it's a really way to you know you
see people like you know maybe people
that watch a little
a little
more casually you know i mean they say
oh i can't believe that they set this up
way back then
and you know it's like well yeah they
didn't really know but uh it's pretty
pretty cool that they they know that we
would be thinking about that and so it
makes you know
it makes a lot of sense for them to to
to go back and
and uh complete it so uh this is the
last um
this is the last super chat i've got if
you've got another one now's the time to
get it in because i'm going to get out
of here it's uh just crossed the three
hour
threshold and i got another video i got
to make so um
it seems like a good time to uh
to take off
and uh
i'm not seeing any more so i'm going to
i'm gonna i'm gonna do that i'm gonna
say thank you thanks for everyone who
came out
um
i see scott down there in the chat uh
definitely he uh definitely check out
his channel he's um he's been helping
out uh modding and i really appreciate
that so go and check out his content
i'll definitely be back
in uh you know after the finale
sergio c thank you for the two dollars
gene will eat heal that would be a twist
everyone's expecting a different uh
outcome with that so
that would that would definitely be a
twist uh so yeah thanks guys thanks for
making this so much fun thanks for
coming out thanks for asking good
questions and giving me a chance to talk
about these things and um
can't believe it this is going to be the
last episode and then tuesday was going
to probably be the last bcs stream that
we ever do so i hope you'll come and
join us for that i hope that uh we'll
you'll check out my
episode 13 recap before that and um
yeah
i'll talk to you guys soon see ya